ladies and gentlemen to be feed a
World's Cup presented by chess.com it is
the long-awaited day of round one of the
second matches all of the top players
and we'll go through them uh they've
gotten a buy they've Advanced the second
round but now it's time for them to
prove they're worth I'm GM day I'm there
at its key and once again it is an honor
and pleasure to be joined today uh by
former world champion the legend
Grandmaster vessel into Paula vesseline
are you excited for all of these top
players including Magnus uh to you know
prove their worth today yeah yeah
definitely Daniel I mean today I think
it's a big day finally oh almost all of
the big guys play uh and it will be
funny to see especially Magnus playing
someone who I think you because he
almost never plays opens so uh someone
um with a huge rating difference but of
course at least they they will play over
the board and uh it's nice that Magnus I
think he likes this mixed events
although I don't believe he should even
even be allowed to play but again uh we
see we'll have Magnus Fabiano and almost
everyone again it's a big day finally
it is let's quickly remind everybody of
format uh we have today of course is
classical day so this is the first match
game of the classical portion of the
second round so the Titan control will
be 90 minutes for the first 40 moves 30
minutes at it at the end as usual with a
30 second increment already a lot of the
players have been knocked out in round
one round one is in the books this is
round two and now they're playing for
significantly greater prizes so that
first prize
3750 well a lot of players have gone
home with that
um but now they're starting to contest
more and more money but obviously you
know people like Magnus they're not
playing for six or ten thousand uh
they're playing for that first place
prize and uh a lot of the players are
playing for qualification to the
candidates
so we'll remind everybody also of the
schedule
uh games are basically every day at 8
A.M eastern time as you already know 5
a.m Pacific including today tomorrow
and after the uh the second match game
there is again going to be a tie Break
um Vaseline you were talking about this
beforehand do you think Magnus is going
for 2-0 or let's say he wins today would
he be okay with the drawer or are they
trying to preserve their rating
I think well I think he's going to try
to beat to zero I don't know it depends
of course but uh you know all in all all
this world cup for him it's probably
more as a training okay of course he
wants to win because he failed the first
two times
um as world champion so I I'm sure he'll
try to win but again uh for him the big
the big event for this year is by far uh
his world championship type match
against neponia so uh I've even been
thinking that there are several
strategies that could make uh Magnus
uncomfortable
because he can't show all his weapons
let's say
yeah that would make very little sension
is probably watching very carefully as
you review some of the top players from
the open section and the women's section
we've got women's world champion
Alexander garage
the women's section is absolutely
stacked as well as is of course the open
section Aviano caruana Ali Reza farusha
is a crowd favorite he will be playing
today as well we'll be following his
game against Java here sundarov very
very closely and some of these top
players they they don't have an easy go
of it but before we go to break we have
a as many of you I see know we have a
little bit of sad news
uh to share as feed day reports Lavon
aronian will forfeit the first game of
the second round at the World's Cup he
was seated into the second round the
Armenian Grandmaster as we see in the
Tweet has had some symptoms a fever
earlier this week and the report
continues even though Iranian feels well
now in order not to risk the safety of
other players it has been decided that
he will withdraw from the first game
against Australian Bobby ching and he
will undergo additional tests before
deciding if he is fit to play tomorrow
if he is fit to play uh vessel and it's
going to be very interesting to see will
he manage uh to close the gap tomorrow
and he will then have to win the tie
breaks but very sad news we wish her
only on the best in fact in a way he is
also unlucky because he he was supposed
to play uh with the white pieces today
so uh I think so yeah I mean uh it means
that uh tomorrow if in order to equalize
he'll need to win with the black pieces
so that's something we've been uh
talking about that uh I mean playing the
first game with white with the black
pieces is I believe is better especially
if you win because then I was claiming
the match is almost over so we'll be if
if that's all true well tomorrow we'll
see we'll have a chance to see in
levon's game if he plays of course of
course and we were sure onion the best
we hope he gets well in place tomorrow
we will go on a quick break as per usual
when we come back as we see Magnus
Carlson and preparations being made for
the round to begin a couple of minutes
break we will fill our coffee cups and
when we come back Magnus Carlson
another's battle in the second match
game uh the second match of the Fida
World Cup we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
World Cup you can see on the big clocks
30 seconds left before the first moves
are executed and we have the bird's eye
view we see a lot of the top players mvl
Magnus they've taken the masks off
literally and figuratively they're
awaiting the start of the round vessel
in and people are always excited when
they see these uh regular
run-of-the-mill Grandmasters playing
Magnus and mvl I think a lot of people
pining for an upset definitely i i i in
fact the first rounds there are in a way
very entertaining because you see uh you
know big rating differences and then
also different openings because probably
what I see now in the really top events
is that there's a lot of uh correct
openings nobody takes big risks but if
you go down uh
of course then this is what I
experienced now in the French league we
have some players with new openings and
openings you would otherwise never face
inner uh top events ah it's funny I just
look at the camera and see a old friend
of mine it's Boris postovsky uh I think
he moved to the United States long ago
and he's a he was uh very very
experienced he still is obviously a
coach and he let the Russian team
several times to the
um to the gold medals in the olympiads
with and without Kasparov
let's see I see and Well on our screen
we have some unknown player with the
black pieces to just play the grunfels
um
that's what do you make of that opening
choice
we'll see okay groomfield of course it
is one of the correct openings many many
forced lines so it is about uh
uh I mean in a way
depends of what white wants so uh Bishop
D2 it's okay it's one of the interesting
moves uh E4 is by far the more popular
uh Bishop the tour I don't know who
would actually was the guy who made it
popular maybe it was Dre if he started
playing it you know I I've I've heard a
joke I don't know if it's true I I was
told a story about driev playing Bishop
D2 and then after Bishop G7 uh E4 Knight
B6 Bishop E3 so he beat someone and then
they just tell him that okay but why did
you actually have to play Bishop D2
because it's known that you're opponent
if after he he never takes on C3 so
he oh he goes Knight B6
the same position with an extra Tempe
absolutely funny yeah you just go you
can go for it yeah
you just didn't know that so uh
obviously the idea is to take on C3 with
the bishop right and it's a I looked
this up as you were sharing that story
vessel in it was first played in 1938 by
kogan Solomon kogan I haven't heard of
this flare and then it was played in
1960. I'm looking for the first strong
player to play it regularly muskolenko
it seems like uh Grandmaster uh Victor
muscolenko who's kind of known for
offbeat openings like The Budapest and
the French he played it three or four
times in the 1980s so maybe
he was really the first one
no I mean he was probably the first one
to play it but I think the guy who
really developed it and found new and
this is why it was probably draf yeah
Alexa of course Russian GM and now there
are uh several okay C5 it's you know I
was commentating uh Gibraltar and in
fact lachno played against Antoinette
Stefano the move C5 and I think if okay
uh
it is in a way it's very typical Palm
sacrifice sometimes in the groomfield
queue temporary saxophone and then try
to recover it and you have development
and the idea of the move C5 is that if
white goes uh E4
you know instead of the move Rook C1 I
think of course the move uh C5 was uh
expected but I what I what I mean is
they give the move C5 is of course what
can take but if he goes E4 instead of
Rook C1 and take on C3
take with the bishop take on D4 and if
white takes with a bishop
then E5
take and check on B4 wow and then uh
White has to go like this and then after
exchange it on C3 and I think we see
seven or queen E5 or queen A5 I think
black has a enough compensation that's
the idea
this seems like a good line to play for
a win
it's you know uh I don't know who played
it first the move C5 but it's uh it's a
very new idea and I think it's a good
one so Rook C1 is probably it's already
a new move uh so it also shows the level
already of the uh even in round two uh a
an idea that is not so popular not so I
mean uh
it's a brand new idea to to go for uh C5
but of of course it was also expected so
um
did Magnus be frustrated here that
martinovich seems to know what to do
after this move like maybe he was
expecting to surprise him but Rook C1
played very quickly and of course just
uh for the chat just explaining that the
ideas after CD the idea is that Knight
takes D5 happens and the bishop on C8
remains undefended so you can't do that
that would be a big mistake of course
and I don't think Magnus is so so uh of
course here another mistake is probably
to play Bishop G7
you know uh because then white wins uh a
pawn by taking on D5 and Rook C5 it
means you have to go back with the queen
and you can take on the queen with the
queen yes but I I think Knights is sick
is Knight C6 is the correct move now and
if white takes which is what I expect
or not uh take on C5 sorry
not on D5 and now just go Bishop G7 I
think this is the you know the natural
way as I said uh why black sacrifices
upon with the idea to Temporary uh get
uh the advantage in the development yeah
something like this and then the
question for white of course is how to
develop this bishop and G3 looks
possible E3 and E4 I see that almost
have been played at least once I mean
she seems natural to me yeah that's true
yeah
but um I think if black takes on C3 of
course white has to take with the bishop
otherwise it spells completely the
structure and then Queen D1 uh taking
with the Rook is not really what white
uh wants to yeah I mean allows Bishop C3
and Bishop B6 for example yes and if you
take with the King then black checks
and then you have to go to E1 and then
maybe I I probably take on C3 maybe and
place probably Bishop E6 and there
should be a way to quickly uh get some
contemplating and equalize
yeah Bishop E6 also maybe bishop F5
looked tempting to me trying to go
Knight P4 but perhaps this is a little
too slow but yeah I mean from the
perspective of making a draw this is an
interesting choice but martinovich it
seems like even if black plays perfectly
it might end up in some Josh end game so
maybe Sasha
analyze this to a draw and in that case
that that's definitely not what magnets
wants is some George Line I'll be honest
with you vessel and I'm a little
surprised at the grunfeld because there
are so many Force lines that end in
basically Josh end games
well it is true but uh also I mean first
of all even though they do have a big
rating difference beating a strong uh
strong Grand Master with the black
pieces is never easy and it sometimes it
depends on on the mood and it can only
happen if uh many times it can only
happen if white takes too many risks and
of course that is something you don't
know but
so you know when I said that Magnus he
plays today uh this year this world
championship match against nepomyasji I
would say uh when I was saying about
um
good strategies against him that would
be maybe not a bad idea for martinovich
to match what could uh I mean what if he
knows if he somehow expect nepomiastes
openings in the match and if you could
guess that happens I think he could try
to match them because even if Magnus has
a good idea I think he would not show it
in Europe right
so I've always felt not comfortable with
showing my good ideas uh against weak
opponents because of course you try to
keep them for the big matches for the
big games so again uh but of course we
don't know what neponia is trying to is
planning to play yet but I'm sure Magnus
already started his preparation so we
can of course
we can
debative
repeats the Petrov the Russian game
he he used to play in the past or it
could be neither we don't know uh but
again uh matching these openings I think
is is a good strategy when you play
Magnus
yeah that's a great point and I wanted
to Echo something you said vessel in
which is that uh I think some people
might look at the ratings and just
assume that it's an easy game for Magnus
and that it would be Unthinkable for
Magnus to accept a draw with black but
it's actually not and you know these
2550 GMS are they're very strong players
they're not they're not just going to
you know to lay down and lose uh and
beating them with the black pieces no
matter who you are is is always very
very difficult and Magnus has had his
struggles with that in the past but
that's not because he's particularly bad
with playing lower rate it's there
they're actually good
and they're not easy to beat
yeah so uh I mean um and in fact with
the yeah they it's it's a saying that uh
the the color the white color
compensates at least 100 points rating
difference but sometimes it could be a
lot more so again a a strong and
experienced Grandmaster well prepared
with the white pieces it's extremely
hard to beat especially if he wants to
play solidly but but the problem with uh
martinovic I think now is that okay
imagine he draws the match the first
game with the white pieces nothing
happens he doesn't even try he plays
solidly and he he plays harmlessly to
just to make a draw and then he loses
the game two with the black pieces it
means he would leave uh the World Cup
and probably without even attacking a
single uh Pawn of Magnus uh so sometimes
it's worth to try to not to you know
just uh to make a draw and and it's a
make a normal game but the the holiday
of course is to advance to the second
round and right I don't know which which
strategy is best I think it's okay what
he does in fact because with the way
it's it's very difficult to win uh
against a strong answer with with the
black pieces of course even with white
if it's not easy I mean we don't I don't
know his openings but uh I don't I mean
if if you play normally you shouldn't be
losing even to Magnus you know yeah you
should know you're you're frapping I I
want to take a quick look at some of the
other top games here starting with uh
Fabiano Corona as the white pieces
against Indonesian GM susanta megaranto
megaranza is very strong um I've always
felt that he's he's quite dangerous and
capable of delivering some upsets so
here we have an Italian and this
fashionable H6 line but to my knowledge
G5 has become popular in recent recent
times but so songs are going D6 and then
not G5 but G6 that's all that so what do
you make of this
um
oh nothing important has happened now
very very typical well it makes a big
difference of course uh if the opponent
is on G6 or G5 but the whole idiom of
course is to uh place the bishop on G7
because it is supposed that on G7 of
course uh I think it's better place than
on E7 because many times what black does
is after Bishop E7 what they do is they
Castle they play rookie 8 bishop f8 and
then fianca to the bishop so of course
now now we do it immediately so it can
be bad
yeah so many times now the the plan is
to you know to film Kettle so uh okay
it's I'm sure there's been hundreds and
hundreds of games in in this line and
with the phone on of course uh with
Apollo G6 of course you can advance to
uh move your knight from F6 in the
future maybe prepare and prepare a five
some so and take with the pawn of course
so and it's a difference the difference
the big difference between take playing
with the pawn on G5 and G6
right that uh that's a good point we'll
be following fabby's fabby's game but
right now it's still very much in its
incipient stages and use giri on board
three he's got the white pieces against
Russian gym Buddies
and it's a kind of a Catalan slav D4 C6
yeah C6 that's interesting Bishop G2 DC
and A4 I I always believed that Knight
E5 is the critical move here and yeah
Bishop B4 probably uh I've even played
C5 here which is a very rare move but
yeah but I really I I believe the move
C5 is just compared to some lines it's
uh we get to the same position but uh
black is Tempe down no if we get to the
lines with Knight A3 and Knight takes C4
somehow uh yeah this is one of the one
of the lines yeah but I mean yeah I
agree many ones the white in fact in
fact the difference is that the pony is
not on A6 but it's on A7 and sometimes
it can even be good for black so it's
not so tragic tragical
um right maybe I don't know
Asian before I don't I I mean uh
did not give it a check on before
well that's one of I think probably
still the move C5 makes sense now
because it makes the move A4 not so
useful I think now C5 it seems that it
seems to me C5 makes a lot of sense now
because the pawn or only four is not
really uh so well placed
yeah I mean let's say White Castles and
then probably just yeah C6 but I I'm
sure Anish knows and there there's been
many many games so if if white takes on
we have these endings with the ending on
uh with after Knight bd2 the pawn is on
A4 but of course C3 doesn't have to uh
to be played maybe maybe okay if Black
Goes Knight E5 still he is not going to
keep the pawn after Knight E5 so right
so C3 is often played to ruin because
the logic is you're going to lose your
Pawn anyway so you might as well try to
ruin white structure you see this move
very frequently and sometimes even white
plays this weird cat and mouse game with
Knight B3 I've seen that as well but
probably here BC is of course and I have
to say that I believe that the pornos on
A4 is is a not worse for sure it's not
worse than on A2 because it doesn't
change the plan White's plan is to play
Knight to B3 or to C4 but I mainly
Knight B3 and then knight from F2 F3 to
D4 so
so I don't think the pawn on A4 is badly
placed and sometimes of course you can
advance and threaten A6
um we'll see uh and the other option I
believe I don't think it's a good one
for black is to play B5 and try to play
for that pawn but I I somehow feel
that's dubious
uh yeah B5 in this position
because yeah my Trend supposed to the G3
slav but yeah the Knight is still on B1
which gives white extra options exactly
because if you go 95 now for example and
black ghost Knight D5
after E4 you can't exchange your the
Knight on C3 for example that's one of
the differences so I don't like the move
B5 we'll see what will happen in fact
yeah so Boris is taking taking a
significant amount of time here it seems
probably he's not so totally out of his
preparation but
but it's maybe contemplating the various
options C5 Bishop B4 B5 we'll keep an
eye on this is a very interesting
opening but there are so many top games
to look at and I definitely want to give
everybody
um a chance to to look at the game of
the top GM that they are rooting for
um of course a crowd favorite we would
be remiss if we didn't spend a good
amount of time in a game of Ali Reza
farouza one of the shining stars
um of the Young Generation he's 2759
unbelievable rating and he has an
accelerated dragon with white against uh
Uzbek GM job who is very dangerous
opponent I mean you blink twice and
somebody like sundarov could score an
upset
but typical accelerated position not
much to say here I think Queen D2 is
standard yeah this is by of course
because the it is very important to keep
the dark Square bishop and obviously the
move Knight G4 uh was a serious threat
saw on almost uh everyone plays Queen D2
of course that would be a big
strategical mistake to let uh exchange
the Knight for the bishop and queen D2
uh in this kind of positions I believe
it's a bit more useful to have the pawn
on F3 instead of the bishop on E2
because sometimes you can place it if
you're white you can place it to D3 in
one move uh but again still that's uh
theoretical and I think now that Bishop
E6 A6 and queen A5 are the typical moves
right Bishop B6 is I'm saying the most
popular
and generally Black's idea is to
orchestrate counter play on The Queen
side You Queen A5 Rook fc8 or four black
ago A6 B5 I'm all right sometimes A5 A5
A4 but it really depends on on how white
puts his pieces as well it is in a way a
matter of if white if black is able to
to break free uh with B5 well these
positions they're always a bit worse for
black but sometimes because uh theories
advance so much sometimes uh it's almost
nothing so we'll see uh I I expect this
game to last long it's not going to be a
very tactical one I believe but uh well
of course you you never know
um I mean it does I don't think firoz is
going to play H4 and launch an attack I
mean it's right that just seems
we don't know uh maybe he finds he he
knows something very original and uh
we'll see
yeah I mean we don't see the accelerated
at the top level too many times it does
have a summer dubious reputation but
perhaps cindara prepared it very deeply
and that can be very dangerous I mean
it's a pretty narrow narrow opening I
think the problem of Marazzi it has the
reputation maybe not dubious but just a
passive one that's what I believe so
that's the reason so it's once you I
mean uh what what players on top level
look is to clean
and to have the clean path to equality
so this kind of passive positions where
white can go back and forth I think is
the typical uh it's not that they're
lost or very bad but that's typical the
the kind of positions that white that
black tries to avoid
right that's absolutely true and there
are so many top games to look at all of
the GMS seated into round two are of
course now playing
um not necessarily a top board but I
want to ask your opinion uh wrestling on
something near and dear to my heart in
the game between Indiana and samachevsky
we have a Berlin and white played Bishop
A4 in this position I've been playing
this move
for about a year Ray Robson played it
against me four or five years ago in a
U.S Championship I was black I managed
to win the game but I'd never seen this
move before and ever since then I've
started playing it with white it's an
incredibly dangerous weapon if black
does not play accurately
um Vaseline what are your thoughts on
this on this Gambit line
yeah absolutely I I believe there was
not long ago there was a game with when
white
achieved a crushing Victory it was maybe
played in Paris or or one of these uh
events that Gary organizes and then uh I
think nepalmy asked you won very quickly
against someone and then even Gary
tweeted something that he said that he
liked the idea well I don't believe it's
the refutation of the Berlin otherwise
that would be too easy it doesn't make
that much logic but of course it's an
interesting weapon and it will be
interesting to see this game but I I
somehow suspect
tomachevsky is prepared I think of
course
in this kind of situation all these
gambits it's a mistake to be greedy with
black and for example taking makes no
sense in this position so it is better
to return materials even sometimes and
to complete the development and have
your this is a normal square and not to
be greedy I mean that would be probably
exactly how computer would have played
20 or 30 years ago take and take and get
made it right yeah
but but of course now I think they're so
strong now that even now they are
evaluating maybe the position like
equality or who knows maybe even a bit
better for white I don't know but of
course yeah natural movies Bishop E7
here or D3 I don't know maybe D3 is all
also makes sense yeah Bishop B7 CD and I
think B5
um is a fashionable fashionable line
trying to accelerate Black's development
and then there's both Bishop B3 Bishop
C2 and okay there's a lot of theory here
but yeah black is fine Black is Black is
maybe in slightly better if he plays
accurately if he knows yeah
yes yeah so but to muchevsky is you can
see his clock at one hour eleven so he's
been
you know he's been lost and thought in
this position and that worries me a
little bit definitely a game to keep to
keep track of because
yeah if black does not play precisely
then he could definitely land in a
significant amount of trouble
um another matchup that interests me a
lot you know even selfishly is Sam
Shanklin against vlador jabala Sam of
course is is a good friend of mine we're
from the same
part of the world and uh he's very very
hard-working GM
you know he's flawed his way to 2700 but
he's facing a very formidable opponent
we've got sort of a typical iqp position
yeah yeah of course so now the big thing
is that the pawn is on H6 so of course I
believe what has happened is that white
had his Bishop on G5 and the normal
reaction after being attacked on uh with
H6 is to play Bishop H4 but instead Joe
Bob has played played his Bishop on F4 I
think ah H6 was played before that uh
honestly I've never seen that uh but of
course it's so after Bishop F4 uh Knight
1966 so I'm not afraid of D5 yeah I yeah
it looks very natural to play the move
D5 but I I believe that in that case uh
black would have exchanged uh and then
played just go Queen F6 probably so yeah
attacking division 104. and what about
taking with the bishop on D5 I think it
also deserves attention no instead of
taking with the Knight yeah trying to
establish a knight in the center it
makes sense to me because uh Bishop F7
is a threat
so taking with the bishop with the
Knight would follow and then the Knight
is quite annoying I would say so I don't
know it it looks to me very natural okay
of course I would prefer to have my
Bishop on D5 instead of a knight but the
Knight is also strong you know and uh I
don't know exactly what
um
maybe not taking on D5 is the idea but
down in the queen somewhere maybe Queen
E8 or something 28 could be twins it
makes sense yeah but then I take on C3
and take the bishop no and then I
totally fine that I'm totally fine yeah
so Queen is probably equalizing maybe so
that it makes sense it it explains why
uh uh jibaba played Bishop D3
which which doesn't seem like it signals
you know the most ambitious approach is
Sam could go 97 here and try to go for a
D5 Square blockade but it okay it's yeah
these iqp positions could go either way
you can also go rookie eight and uh by
playing rookie 8 he stops the move uh D5
almost forever you know and then the
bishop my goal to have f8 and then
Bishop H6 is never going to be a threat
so that's another option I would say uh
but but yeah and of course these
structures when you give your Bishop on
C3 they're a bit worse always and I
don't really think it's a good idea to
uh to give the two the pair of Bishops
and this uh hanging pawns they because
that gives good Dynamics for white for
example if you take and play 95 of
course then Bishop it only makes sense
if Black's able to play B5 and stop the
advance of the pawn but it it that
doesn't happen then of course that's not
a good idea
right white gets all this play on the
center on the king side
yeah that that makes a lot of sense
um on the camera of course is uh the
game of Daniel dubov
who is in a grunfels with gukesh now
let's see which line was played Bishop
c492 main line
Knight C6 Bishop E3 and here Dubach took
Queen A5 and queen A3 I'm not too
familiar with these intricacies castles
Mr G4 yeah I mean when I Was preparing
for my world championship match against
vision and oh and uh the candidates
magic against kamski then I prepared
this line for white and taking and
taking immediately on A5 and playing
queen queen A3 then back then we
considered that not not so good for
black but of course that was uh more
than 10 years ago and maybe things has
have changed I think the
the correct move was to immediately Play
Bishop C3 maybe I don't know why so but
uh again again we are talking about uh
uh more than 10 years ago uh
preparations and of course computers
there they so strong now that uh just a
little detail changes everything so it
could be I don't I don't think do both
experiments you know so
um for sure he knows something and uh it
will be interesting to see this bishop
G4 yeah Bishop G4 it's it's a good way
to to pre first of all uh after the move
F3 which I believe is The Logical one
now uh White doesn't have uh the square
E3 for for his Bishop right so just
Bishop D7 perhaps of course yes and of
course sometimes you have this uh checks
from C5 if if white decides to advance
so
um
so I guess Bishop C3 would make sense
yes yes and then
C8 there's probably a lot of moves here
castles yeah I guess it's it's a typical
position but the difference is that uh
the bishop is not on E3 it's on C3 uh
but again I I just don't remember uh
because it's considered not uh not the
main line there are many other uh
lines
for black that are considered better
than taking on playing Queen A5 and
queen E3
right so do Bob well Dubai of course is
known for choosing very uh you know very
little known lines yeah that gaming it's
kayaking in the Italian where he played
d4b4
which uh which caught Sergey completely
by surprise
uh so we'll see how he manages this
bishop G4 F3 Bishop D7 has been played
and now gukesh is is thinking
um we'll keep an eye on on this game I
know dubov is a crowd favorite always
produces interesting games we will take
our first break of the day when we
return a lot of these games still in
their opening stages but some of them
are already heating up so we'll bring
all of that action to you after a very
quick break don't go anywhere we will be
right back
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Worlds Cup we've got Nifty and
fashionable new merch available use
promo code Worlds Cup all one word for
10 off
that ends August 7th so make sure to go
to go.chess.com
merch use promo code World Cup for 10
off all chess.com merch
and we are watching round two game one
in front of us Magnus Carlson's game
against Sasha martinevic and we were
discussing in this position the end game
after Knight takes C3
but Magnus deciding to go for a more
unbalancing option and going night db4
vestalin what do you make of this
well it's a very natural reaction
because um
uh what black wants to do now is of
course he wants to play Knight D3 in
these kind of positions they always with
without the light Square Bishop there's
always a compensation but I'm just
thinking about what could have been a
martinovic's idea but for as from what I
see the difference of course is this
compared to the line we considered
before if black takes on C3 instead of
the move Knight B4
uh instead of yeah then
Bishop takes and and now after taking on
D1
King takes and now in in the position
where the Knight was uh on F3 and black
hat Castle now Rook the Apes is simply
not possible and which makes uh a
difference
and that's why Magnus
has decided to play
um night before I believe it's still I
believe it's still some computer
analysis and uh my feeling is this kind
of position black always has
compensation
yeah I mean why to play A3 and then the
Knight goes to D3 and then we get this
position
I mean to me Queen E2 seems very natural
and then I guess 95 is interesting but
black could also take the equation
sometimes in these end games that D3
Square becomes weak so you can have the
Knight go to E5 but I don't know yeah I
mean right if uh now after Knight 95
white is almost forced to Castle and
then if black wants he can either jump
to G3 and recover the pawn on C5 or play
Knight C4 I don't know it also looks
tempting so uh but again my feeling is
uh they're both remembering their
preparation
so it would be interesting to see or
honestly it's a brand new uh line and
maybe there's still some new ideas to be
found and a lot of games to be played
because again C5 uh it's just a new a
newer it's a new idea I think it's a
maybe uh I don't know when it was first
played but I saw it not long ago on only
in Gibraltar so
yeah so currently martinovich is
thinking after Knight dv4 he's
definitely probably A3 is at the top of
his candidate move list I'm not sure
what else you could play in fact in fact
yeah because if you go uh Knight F3 then
white black can also go Bishop G4 for
example you know and right
then and then still sooner late either
you you force the the you know the
Knight to jump to D3 uh or you or if you
move your Bishop to E3 then it means I
think that even most like sometimes
Knight D4 are possible but of course uh
black has to White has to consider even
moves like Bishop takes C3 and Knight A2
sometimes it works uh for black
maybe right now but at some point yeah
maybe so maybe take on D1 and then long
castle and then Knight D3 with a very
good compensation
yeah fair enough
um okay so we'll we'll keep an eye on
this one I want to take a look at the
ladies section as well
so let's switch to that one for for a
little while
okay we have uh to her Genova against
karachina with a clearly a transition
error I don't think B5 Knight bd2 was
played
[Music]
um
but okay this is just a typical Italian
I think she played Bishop B6 Knight bd2
yeah it's a it's obviously some mistake
um
well this kind of positions of course uh
there's a difference uh computers you
know they like to have uh the pawn on A5
because
they believe that by placing the pawn to
on A5 and not on A6 which was uh the
more popular move in the past uh black
gain space and then of course it stops
uh the move B4 and sometimes even uh
a five four white uh is considered uh a
bit better in these structures and of
course now it makes a big difference
whether white wants to take on E6 or not
but I I think if you if white allows uh
taking on on C4 then gradually it should
lead to to equality I mean because uh
sooner late uh what white has to do is
to if Bishop takes C4 Knight C4 then
sooner late white has to play I think
Bishop E3 also and then these kind of
positions uh okay they are playable but
it's not much of course right yeah sort
of a classic Italian position we'll keep
an eye on this one but not much to say
here at the moment I noticed one funny
thing is in the game of Iranian
um I am she's very very strong Sarasota
uh
she has the same well no that's not the
same line as duboff but similar idea
Bishop B3 395 Bishop D2 Queen A3 so this
maneuver of the queen to A3 and the
grunfels
uh has has become powerful but this
probably is more common than the line
Dubach chose to play
yeah it's three well it's it's a logical
move because it stops the more Bishop
page G4 forever but it's at the same
time uh waste of time I mean uh yeah
I've seen this uh Queen A5 Queen A3 is
typical sometimes white first takes uh a
black first takes on D4 and checks and
then goes Queen A3 sometimes not
and um and then I think it's still of
course that very very theoretical and I
think it has a good reputation for black
uh right of course no more inequality of
course I think
yeah yeah now this is
uh now Gary played Black
against gristook I think he blundered uh
his
piece very quickly after the opening uh
could you see one that's something new
and um but what I was saying is that
after instead of Queen A5 Queen A3 he
took on D4 he played Knight C6 and then
he played F5 I think after Bishop B2 I
think he played a five
and yeah and then castling
and he took on e4 check on C4 or
something like that yeah and Knight G5
and then well that's all theoretical
and then he simply uh almost immediately
after the opening he took on H3 and it
took it turned out uh just losing it was
Knight takes D4 I think this was what
happened 94 Knight F7
Queen D6 was played and I think Rook E1
and maybe now uh Gary took on H3 okay it
was a Blitz game uh and it turned out
that it's simply losing after Bishop
takes D4 and Rook D and after Bishop D4
rookie four and then he simply resides
oh wow because there's a GH is coming
yeah and if you take the Rook then I
take with check and this is just almost
right yeah almost made
um
so but again there are games after Queen
D6 rookie one I think the other moves
but again uh that's only one of the
options black has and and queen A5 Queen
A3 is the other one and then of course
you can play F5 and
as Gary did so so we get to this end
ending which uh it's a strange mixture
um I think now compared to the other
positions the pawn is on H3 which is a
better uh
because I think the I just I'm just
trying to figure out uh who's uh gotten
extra Tempe so okay uh I I guess quiz
you won
I don't know about moves like Queen A4
maybe they're not so good because okay
if you take like this and take on D4 uh
we got maybe a bit better favorable
um
version of uh an ending because maybe
the pawn is already in on H3 compared to
to the other line and then of course
because the king hasn't been moved uh
white has the extra option to Castle if
he wants to
so I don't know now Rook d8 looks
logical but again the pawn is already on
H3 so I I would I would prefer white a
bit maybe it doesn't make a big
difference but it's always nice you know
to have extra extra move yeah for sure
yeah I mean Sarah is she's I think she's
a good very good positional player she's
got opening preparation so she has a
chance to go far in this tournament I
I'm also looking around on some of the
other games in the ladies section and
okay so far not too much not too many
interesting positions most of the games
are still in their opening opening stage
where you might have a quick result in
uh the match between that's all yield is
from turkey and uh tanzani from China
who is you know what definitely one of
the one of the favorites
um this was a tarash-esque kind of line
which led to a quick end game and lots
of pieces were traded Bishop D7 Knight
C6 everything traded on C6
and I guess white is symbolically better
but I don't think it's anything serious
as the king easily defends
a slightly damaged spawn structure this
will be a drop yeah it's close to draw
but of course black has to be a bit
careful because sometimes the pawn
angles can be even lost because uh White
has a bit more for example I guess
imagine you go King C4 and then black
tries to take and then play group d8
this I'm not sure it's a draw let's say
yeah that's I mean the king positioning
is also incredibly dominant so the
correct way to is I believe is for black
to uh keep one pair of Rooks and uh and
uh not to go for uh for uh phone ending
but of course it's very little it should
be a draw uh of course it should be a
draw
yeah and it seems like this is perhaps
so she she is aware probably of some of
the subtleties in this line given that
the clock situation
so that might be you know not a very
interesting game but this might be our
first results in the women's section we
have so many
how many strong match-ups even on some
of the lower boards and we'll be
bringing that to you as the games get
interesting let's transition back for
now to the
open section martinovich by the way as
I'm doing that has played Knight F3 yeah
which is a move we discussed in Vaseline
you mentioned I think Bishop G4 being a
possibility it is a very natural
reaction to moves like knight uh F3
because okay of course black can also
Castle it can be that bad but I would
say in Bishop G4 makes sense because
it is a very typical uh
idea to try to exchange the Bishop from
C8 first of all you develop your piece
and then of course one once the Knight
is exchanged then uh black has the
option to jump to D4 and it's a very
important square and Luke's compensation
but of course it is
if black had an extra Pawn One More Pawn
then I would say Blackwood was is better
but because he he simply has a
compensation maybe but maybe no more
um it will but again uh I don't really
like all this setup for white because
they're exposing too many squares
um right I'm not saying quite sure about
Knight F3 I think white should have
played A3
yeah it could be could be but it's also
true that in a way when you play a move
like A3 you somehow invite the Knight to
go away it wants to go
so yeah it just feels like here black
has so many options though castles
Bishop G4
yeah it's about it's a question if white
can find a more useful move than A3
rather than uh the perfect would be of
course if white is able to chase the
Knight back to A6 if you first prevent
the uh secure the square D3 like with
Bishop E3 for example and then A3 but of
course I don't think it works simply
because uh uh yeah I can take yeah and
then taking with the Kink is not
something that uh you want to do take
for the rock there's Knight C2 and
definitely don't play like this
so that can always happen in these
positions that would be a mouse sleeping
an online online World Cup maybe but not
right exactly over the board
yeah I mean you we've seen a share of
gains that end this way but not not at
this level
okay so martinovich is our Magnus is
thinking after Knight F3 I I want to
maybe look at some of the games we
haven't looked at yet
um starting with memory of against uh
crecore
and we have a lot of moves like this is
a Vienna
I mean this is very this is a very
theoretical line takes Bishop C4 C5 this
is all very well known
going for this line also very well known
as far as I know
and basically white leaves the plot on
D4 for the time being and instead
institutes this kind of cramp on Black's
position Bishop is you know not easily
developed
recore
okay my arms sort of accumulating pieces
on the king side here you're right but
as you see what black tries to do is to
he wants to give the pawn back in fact
he's not planning to defend upon with
Knight C6 the default Pawn because uh in
that case I think that would be much
easier for white to play for a king side
attack and he returns the pawn with the
idea to
um equalize and sometimes the pawn on E5
of course is weak so uh
in a way some again uh
this structure because also uh we have
opposite uh Square Bishops and then uh
it's a matter if white is able to launch
an attack or not and sometimes I think a
good Square for for
um Black Knight is f8 and that's one of
the reason Knight C6 is not played you
know
yeah
I mean so what should Chuck do here I
guess first question oh no Queen G4
blunders this fun that's a bit of a
problem for white I guess maybe bishop
C2 oh so Bishop B1 Bishop B one yes but
again uh I guess Knight D7 attack
attacks the pawn
and then still you have to waste time
somehow and it's clear you're not going
to mate me with Queen C2 because then
Knight would go to C8
so right and why did you take but I'm
not impressed by this end game I think
this is a draw but I think I would even
take with the pawn because then I
somehow also attack you know the the on
E5 and then yeah super solid but of
course white can play moves like uh F4
and then if if he puts his Knight on e4
play G3 uh probably it's a bit better
but nothing special you know yeah Korea
he seems pretty solid here and you know
I think record is underrated if anything
maybe he's a little bit more well-rested
after well even though he did have a
tiebreaker yesterday but you know he had
so much trouble getting to Russia and I
think that he you know given his
chess.com I've seen a lot of his Blitz
Games he can hang with Hikaru he can
hang with the best of them
and I I think he's definitely one of
those guys who you know might slip under
the radar and and score an upset so
chakra
he's got to be feeling the heat here
although I you know I I know Shakira
quite well played many times against him
and I think it's exactly the type of
position he's very good at with white
because it's there's a lot of Dynamics
and he likes to attack and I think he's
very creative so uh as we see all his
pieces there aren't uh they're all
really developed and uh I mean of course
it's probably also a theoretical game
for the moment but still it's the
position that where he can uh create uh
many Fantastic ideas you know
yeah my mediara was so impressed such a
dynamic creative player he uh he visited
uh San Jose
um for Chef Camp of course when I was
living in California several times in a
row and it was a pleasure to spend time
with them just analyzing the shock is
incredible he's so full of ideas and
Creative Concepts so I agree with you of
excellent I think there definitely is
potential on the king side here for
white
yeah that's a game I I believe will be
very sharp I don't think uh Shakira is
going to play positionally here he'll
always uh try I'm expecting him to try
to uh mess up the things here yeah he's
gonna things things are going to happen
okay uh another game at the top we
haven't checked into yet is Mario body
against MBM or anybody
uh advanced in the first round through a
forfeit and elshon is he is uh living in
in my state right now so I guess
selfishly
um I'm interested in his game but of
course MBL MBL is mvl and interestingly
Maxine played and played a Rouser
probably avoiding more preparation he
has of course had had his struggles
recently in the night off very deep
struggles
and here he probably avoids preparation
of the Rouser well maybe he just wants
to uh
make his future future opponents uh the
preparation preparation of his future
opponents more difficult because uh in a
way of course I I've been all my life a
neither player but the only problem is
that sometimes you become too much
predictable you know it's a good opening
I don't think it has a reputation but it
is true that you one has to remember
many Force lines and it's not a bad idea
from time to time to change you know so
here uh yeah it is very important
exactly and I think it's been
played already several times and it's a
new idea when Black Goes Rook B8 uh
I honestly uh
in the past uh black was playing
sometimes B4
um
but it is very typical what's been done
so far
um
let's say H5 is important also because
it stops uh the advanced
white white pawns on the king side so
all this is very it's a good maneuvering
uh Bishop D3 and then in the past black
was playing B4 but now Rook B8 was
played first because I believe that uh
black has some different idea uh maybe a
5a4 first and
maybe I'm not uh for some reason uh
black stopped playing the move B4
immediately
right and 92 E5 that's also very typical
restricting the Knight stopping it from
going to D4 and Alshon Bishop G5 the
difference is that the square uh C4 is
not available for white now compared to
if black played B4 and of course the
pawn is not hanging so
um so yeah E5 it stops the move uh 94
yeah and Bishop B6 I think is a very
typical follow-up yes
I mean queen I mean if you think it
looks like black structure is quite good
only problem is that sometimes it's not
you have to keep your king in the center
so uh but again it's maybe a good way to
play for win because uh for example here
uh it's not so clear what white has to
do because F4 it's not the move that you
want to do to play because right even F5
is not really a big deal and going back
to C3 would be probably mistake with the
Knight
instead of f4
right probably because of B4 right yeah
and then because yeah uh
when I was a kid I was taught that okay
the porno D6 is weak but once you jump
on D5 with a piece and that piece is
exchanged uh we got a structure when uh
it's not it's not the pawn on D6 is not
not no weak no weak anymore uh so this
is a very typical structure I don't know
if it will happen but uh and I don't
know if black has to take with the
bishop
but again
um I've seen that you know when uh White
goes Knight E2 and provokes E5 and back
to C3 uh it is not so uh surprising but
again for example Bishop E6 it's obvious
that G4 I don't think white can play G4
and Knight G3 of course uh you can
ignore and wait for the Knight to go to
to F5 but of course black can also go G6
and and and then maybe Knight F1 makes
sense and because it's a good place for
the Knight on E3 or maybe now F4
sometimes yeah it makes more sense uh
but I think
Maxim he he feels very well this kind of
positions and he knows exactly what to
do it will be yeah I like the idea of
going ig3 actually too to try to induce
G6
um elshon is thinking yeah Maxine played
B4 quite the time Advantage for black as
well so Maxine probably very confident
in these positions
and I think we are repeating some game
maybe my impression they're repeating
some game
at least Maximus maybe uh maybe else
John is is not aware of it maybe but
again I I once you have uh you have to
somehow improve the your pieces and then
uh one of the one of the advices I I've
received as a as a kit is that if you
don't know what to do you should simply
try to improve the your worst piece and
I mean if you see it's a it's I would
call it's a kind of an opposition you
have a knight or need to restricted by a
Pawn on E5 so there's no you can't
advise it would Advance with your knight
uh right now so you have to to find a
better place for it so that's why uh
night night G3 makes sense I think and
these kind of positions also uh it looks
like sometimes black can advance his
pawns to A5 A4
and B3 but many times in fact these
pawns are more a weakness than a
strength so white doesn't have to be
afraid of
an attack
of the entire advance
yeah yeah I've seen a lot of games kind
of backfire uh with this attack
backfiring
looking around at some of the other
games
um stuff is happening in the carwana
megaranto game but nothing nothing
insane we've got a lot of Legends
playing wrestling we have of course a
Boris galphon we have Peter swidler
um let me call up the gelfon game and
even though some of them you know gal
fund is below 2700 but it doesn't matter
he still bore his girlfriend and he's a
legend I didn't even know yeah I mean
he's a both both are in fact X World Cup
winners I mean uh in in swindler he he
was close to win uh for second time he
he was leading 2-0 as I mentioned uh on
the previous days against kariakin he
was leading to zero and there was he was
with huge advantage in the third game
close to winning
he was asking for fear for his third win
and then he blundered and then finally
he also lost the tie break and it was
very tragical uh defeat for him but
again he won once the World Cup and he
and girlfriend won the year he qualified
uh after later on it was I think he won
in 2009 maybe so but of course
[Music]
a lot of time ago it is true
Morris very creative though age 54 in
this position
I don't know if the move through K8 Rook
A7 is the critical because I always had
the impression that B5 was the move here
but I'm not so sure I mean I thought
that B5 was critical at uk7 was uh
passive but I'm not sure because okay
it's uh it's another move you want to
play but it's also true that through K7
is passive so I I don't follow this line
uh
yeah Rook a seven Queen comes back
yelpon trying to prepare Knight G5 yeah
we are now opening up the position we
already have a very interesting old uh
opening it's uh different so black has
two Bishops but also the Rook on A7 is
uh a bit of
and and white has uh the uh advantage of
the development so uh we'll see if he'll
be able to you know to uh improve and to
make use of uh his uh advantages in the
development I don't know but yeah but
it's it's a good strategy to to reduce
the tension with exchanges so for
example I think if white plays something
like Bishop D3 then I would rather take
on e4 play C6 solidly and then H6 maybe
and see what to do next uh mm-hmm and
rookie eight but uh
but yeah it's we'll see
yeah Boris taking taking his time so
many legends playing and all of the top
GMS it's a fascinating round in the
World's Cup we will take a short break
and uh when we come back in a few
minutes we'll bring you more of the
action from round two of the fide Worlds
Cup we'll be back in a few
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the feed a World Cup
chess.com is your exclusive twitch home
for the video feeds for this year's
World Chess Championship join us for the
best coverage around as we watch this
year's players the defending Champion
Magnus Carlson and of course John
napomnishi Battle for the title The
World Chess championships aren't coming
your way in November to chess.com mark
your calendars it's going to be an
absolutely Epic World Championship and
we will have
the video feeds for you and here we have
a video feed on Sasha martineovich as
Magnus is walking around the tournament
Hall he seems pretty happy with what's
been going on in his game vessel and it
seems like our team we just lost control
a little bit
well okay uh nothing really uh tragics
has happened so far uh I believe again
that white should have a black should
have a compensation but maybe no more I
I mean now I just don't see another move
except
well uh Queen E2 looks to me like a
natural move now but then I would if I
were black okay Rook d8 could be played
but I would even take on C2 I've been
thinking now about this position during
the break and then Bishop Bishop G4 is a
very natural option but then I probably
Bishop B3 and then I somehow uh take on
D4 if you do if you play 94 but then uh
I also like the move Bishop E6 because
the check from C4 is not very pleasant
for white I mean and I just don't know
how to stop it uh because group D1 is
even losing maybe because then Bishop C4
checks and then he should be 431 Bishop
B3 or First bishop in season so it looks
pretty uh good for black now uh
my feeling is of course that like
squares are very important and uh the
lack of Pawn is more than compensated by
the compensation black has I don't know
if black is better but certainly it has
good uh Magnus has a good very good
compensation item and of course I'm not
sure about the move Queen E2 at all
yeah I mean also I was thinking Bishop
G4 Bishop E3 uh maybe F5 is a little bit
nasty for white because takes takes and
then F4 Knight D5 this this just doesn't
look good for white yes somehow there
are many many options for black of
course uh White could
uh include the moves H3 and Bishop H5
but that doesn't change much yeah
definitely black has very many options
and it's good strong uh compensation
uh but again it's maybe a bit too early
to to to claim Black's advantage
right and if I if I will black what
white I would be thinking about
simplification maybe bishop E3 is better
than Queen E2 in fact
and then if you take with the queen on
D1 no I mean Bishop E3 is better than
Queen E2 probably which was just played
by the way Queen martinovich playing
Queen two Magnus immediately taking oh
no no sorry that was me
yeah we need your husband played but
Magnus is Magnus is thinking okay so you
can claim if I just takes on if Magnus
takes on E2 you can claim you're even
quicker than Magnus in taking the
correct decisions right exactly that's
that's the goal
um but I think Magnus okay he's deciding
probably between rook d8 and 22 but I
think Queenie 2 is so natural because it
forces the king onto a very undesirable
Square yeah definitely this one seems
Pleasant for Magnus yeah I've been
thinking that if Magnus plays groomfield
today it means that he's probably not
planning to play in the world
championship match it's not that there's
anything wrong with the uh with grufo
there's an opening but uh usually you
don't show your open so easily uh your
plans no that would be too obvious uh oh
but it's a good choice because I think
it's a it's a uh I mean it's a very
correct opening uh it doesn't have a
refutation and it's very complicated so
if if uh uh
believes that he might face groomfield
that that would take really a lot of
effort for his team uh he'll they would
need to spend a lot of time to will find
ideas with the white pieces because
again I don't think you can really
refute drumfeld so right the Magnus uh
he's playing uh some big game maybe some
secret game with by choosing drumfots
you're right that's the psychological
um complexity of what you choose to play
before a world championship matches is
incredible it's all about you know not
only what you play but what you don't
play and what you do play and how you
play it
um I I do I am aware that it shows that
Carolina has already won I'm quite sure
that he hasn't I think this is a simple
transmission error uh probably some sort
of a mistake that of course the position
Still Remains very complex
but um I I'm realizing it shows one zero
so if the camera pans on on Fabiano
we'll be able to see that uh see
confirmation of that but I'm confident
that susanzo has not resigned in this
position
it doesn't look like uh he resigned but
uh it is white to move so
um
that's Geary
uh or like that that is caruana's game
and neither of them are running game
they yeah it doesn't the white spot is
ticking so I think the game is going on
actually I think he's it's Gary's game I
it's not zero it's not the second boss
it's the fourth uh ah it's the fourth
board ah you mean the the other one the
one on the camera no that is current one
that is Corona's game I think oh the
second is the Karana and then you have
giri uh next
yeah but neither of them are at the
board you know one thing that could have
happened is maybe the pawn 94 triggered
the the dgt board and it thought that it
was a king you know because you got to
put the Kings on e4 and D5 I don't know
whatever it is it's a little weird that
neither of them are at the board
um but definitely I think White's clock
is ticking so
it's weird
well I believe white should maybe close
with D5 here because uh my opinion is
that if uh taking on D4 is allowed then
um well I would prefer the bishop on B7
in that case but even on D7 it's not bad
that bad I think
um and of course the other option is to
Simply play rookie one you know so after
D5 I don't know if Black's going to be
able to uh because the Rook the queen is
on E7 and it's different for example
moves like Knight H7 preparing F5 they
they could be running to rookie one and
then if you go at five take and 94 that
makes the difference between the queen
on d8 on on so maybe it's not a good
place for the queen if you want to play
it five uh but again I I think
white if white wants to play for an
advantage he should close and then go
for long game
and next to restrict the Knight on A5 by
B3
and
and it's usually F5 it's very
double-edged sometimes it backwards
backfires for for
um for black
right I and I think D5 yeah definitely
also limits the Knight on A5 you could
play B3 at some point and make it very
difficult for that Knight to rejoin
Society in fact if you think the the
pawn on D5 in a way it cuts the position
in two blacks blacks uh position into
the tour flanks you know I mean
something's got to be a vesseling right
because neither of them has returned to
the board in a while now maybe they've
went to look for an Arbiter for some
reason maybe there's a clock issue I I'm
not confident but it could be because
they're both in the bathroom clock is
not running I mean even even they had
both uh not on the board the clock
should be running but Something's
Happened uh that's clearly about smells
wrong yeah we let's hope it's only a
technical problem because I just don't
think they should I don't think they
agree to draw already right yeah that
would be a that would be absurd
um or maybe someone is getting tested
who knows
someone's coughing yeah that well we'll
try to we'll try to keep uh keep tabs on
the situation update you as as we find
out more but at this point we know just
as just as little as everybody else
but okay well do you think it's it can
be that if you somehow run into trouble
then you could somehow complain to to
the armpit to your your opponent is
coughing and ask you ask Arbiter to test
him sure yeah I mean that that that's
possible but in any case we'll we'll
move on for now if we if we find out
more about the situation and we can
share then we will but in the meantime
we're just going to assume that it's a
technical issue
I want to check in to the um well maybe
not this is the jababa game has gotten a
little bit interesting we do have the
hanging Pond structure here
I kind of like badur's position here
yeah because uh but but again
um
it's black it's white to move oh so
that's
looks very good then because
um
I mean first of all moves like Queen
E4 provokes uh F5 and that's a move that
of course uh
weakens a lot blacks uh position but
it's not the end because imagine okay
the natural move here is Queen E4 F5 for
example and then Queen moves to E2
and here Knight D5 could be play well 95
is running to C4 but maybe Knight G6 is
better than Knight D5 no
I like white of course uh solid probably
for black of course yeah
but 96 simply black white exchanges uh
knighted C6 I think take no and then
should be better for white samples C4
maybe just pile up on that pawn yeah no
this is this is a serious advantage
this is a serious Advantage so badur
um but of course we don't know if uh
Knight C6 has to be played I I believe
Knight G6 is maybe better the night uh
the night C6
but even that's not so clear I think but
again Queen E4 is only one move and H5
also makes sense because I don't know
what exactly even if you take only five
then uh next move is not that clear it
means that Queen C7 has to be played and
then after Queen E4 a move like G6 is
only move
which is not a move you want to play in
fact with black but uh
I mean I I was considering taking on E5
with black
and and then playing Queen C7
right so you say explain C7 Queen E4
yeah
and then
takes
no maybe that maybe not two but uh maybe
Queen F4 is better because uh uh looks
better for white but but it's true that
um
the move
H5 is
interesting but uh more natural is to
provoke immediately uh the pawn on F5
it looks that white got some Advantage
here
right definitely definitely jababa is is
in front I want to take a look at a
couple of crowd favorites for sure um
again there are so many games to keep
track of it's very difficult to
you know very very difficult to uh keep
tabs on on everything at the same time
but we're doing our best
um apparently adibon is a winning
position I also wanted to take a look at
prognananda's game
um so pragnananda is playing against
Gabriel sargisian we haven't looked at
this matchup yet
they are in a scotch with Prague with
the white pieces in this first game and
sort of a typical Scotch position I
don't know what to make of this
and already we have a result by the way
sarich and pisho draw their game
so Yvonne Sarge and Alan fish would draw
their first game okay
Cyrus was white
sarich was white yeah and apparently
they had some sort of a theoretical line
led to a repetition
yeah that's it's Italian that is
theoretical yeah that is
wow and Yvonne one would think you would
wanna
be ambitious with wife and maybe he got
suckered into some sort of prep you can
see the clock 45 minutes so probably he
was not definitely he has to repeat
because uh black wants to go Bishop G6
and then uh his white skin is very
exposed as well so uh he's simply forced
to repeat I again I don't know if it's
theoretical but it looks very logical
there's no way to uh you know to look
for something more than that yeah
definitely I I agree so okay
so um Prague and and sardisian are in a
relatively normal position let's take a
quick look at adibon's game
is that it looks like
he might be
rushing it here against uh Delgado
in a F3 Nims though this is looking
incredibly dangerous for black at least
read on the situation
well for the moment of course it's it's
uh I guess black has to take on C5 and
and uh otherwise if it was white to move
uh then of course Queen H5 and queen G6
would immediately win the game
but uh or almost like Queen E7 of course
but Queen C5 for the moment let's say
queen H5 or is met by uh
H6 so we don't have the check from C4
you know
and then yeah so this doesn't work
because for the moment so white has to
do something differently uh it could be
that it could be that uh White has no
modern compensation let's see let's see
the starting position again uh it looks
pretty dangerous but for the month after
Queen C5 I don't see a forced win for
white because even Knight F7 doesn't
work uh you know so let me see maybe it
moves like Knight H7 deserve attention
well what about the screen H5 H6 and
then Knight F7
yeah but of course it can but then again
we we might end up in in some Perpetual
uh but even if I go King H7 and you try
to repeat then I can actually work at
five
oh of course yeah
looks very good thanks King G8 and
Knight H6
yeah that's that's mate that's true it
means that black has to uh to go to
um G8 now and of course white has
Perpetual if he wants to by uh taking on
H6 but it looks like white should be
able to to mate okay so after Knight F7
let's go back then then it means I black
has to Simply take on F7
maybe maybe check on
C3 and go Knight S6 but it looks very
dubious honestly because Knight D7 would
be better instead of Knight A6 but then
I think the the pawn on F5 is hanging so
it means uh
97 I think it doesn't work no instead of
96. yeah this looks dubious of course
because as we see even though the
material black has maybe enough bones
but because the king is so weak and
black is not able to complete his
development as a simple move rookie one
looks like winning so okay let's go back
again for and look for some at the other
defense for black
so Queen C5 knight uh I mean uh
queen queen throw this in but it doesn't
help and after King H1 it's the same
thing yeah it's the same so this is
force yes
his position is going to appear on the
board yeah but then I guess you have to
somehow check it doesn't uh change much
if you don't
and then if you don't have Knight D7 I
think Knight A6 is just losing to rookie
one
so and 97 would be a way to to place an
item uh yeah but now here I have I mean
also hangs but actually look at five
looks very strong because Queen E8 is
Queen f8 and then maybe I'm trying to
survive somehow but yeah but now this
wins I think here and now you can win a
fade seven but I guess it's going this
six even is winning yes no this is
completely winning
yeah adibon is is in is completely
dominating whoops ariban is completely
dominating something something went
wrong in Black's opening because yeah it
was a nimso F3 played this line I've
seen this before yeah but this is
dubious for blocking I I think I think
I've seen this as well yeah ah this
Castle's line yeah yeah this is yeah
it's very dubious for black yeah C5 is a
nice smoke bearing Bishop C4 and then
Queen E2 so wow yeah
looks absolutely crushing for ID
Bonnie's probably going to win his first
game Delgado he's had his struggles in
the world cup and he seem to be
continuing as he just unable to get off
the ground
um apparently Also krikor let's check
back into the creek or Mahmoud yarab
game and then we'll we'll have a look
before I said magnus's game where a lot
of stuff is happening
it looks like krikor is doing great
against uh Mahmoud yarf he's got that
solid Knight on fa you pointed that out
wrestling and
doing fine
um well
let me see because uh still many pieces
on the board and I think white still
have has
certain
ways to to go for an attack but of
course the bishop on C6 uh attacks uh on
it's well placed and it's a question if
white is able to quickly you know uh
push F5 and create some mating threads
that would be nice to to be one uh to
have one extra move and then just to be
able to to transfer the Rook from D4 to
you know to oh gosh CG foreign
makes sense no uh you can't play Bishop
B5 but what black can do is to play Rook
C8 and threaten to play to take on G2
so
um
yeah
so here why would happen
but even that is not the end because
let's let's even try to continue because
uh F5 Bishop G2 Queen takes and uh Queen
takes C4 and Knight F Knight H5 and you
have to push G6 and also looks pretty
dubious you can also check wind if I oh
no
I was gonna try to get the queen of E5
but it doesn't work and then G G6 is
just taking and looks very bad somehow
yeah yeah and
although yeah maybe maybe maybe simply
take on G6 and if Bishop takes G6 then
Queen F1 is the only chance so it could
be still not so simple no
yeah there's some checks on the first
rank but yeah I mean this it still seems
like a position shockery are kind of
likes to create chances in
yeah
seems good exactly I expect white to try
to keep the rook and then maybe even
suck suck suck it at some point with the
idea to push F5 I don't think mama jarov
is trying to think about playing
positionally although even traditionally
white has a very sound uh space
advantage and even sometimes the endings
are better you know indeed yeah this is
uh this is a very interesting position
and as you predicted it'll be sharp
let's check take a quick look at
magnus's game before we go on another
short break
uh stuff is happening in that game now
as you suggested vessel and Magnus went
for Bishop E6 instead of Bishop G4
martinovich
uh jumped into D5 with his Knight and
Magnus snaps off that pawn on B2 so we
might see Rook B1 Bishop A3 Rook B7
happen
very sharp end game but that would be
that would immediately lead to equality
after Bishop C5 Rook C1 and Knight D4 I
think uh
then blackish I think I believe Rook C2
has to be expected instead of Rook B1
but right because now taking on A3 is
not a good uh idea but
um and because of Rook B1
and I don't and the bishop is in trouble
yes sorry Rook A1 or okay one stronger
but uh of course after Rook C2 uh I
somehow expect
yeah but well for the moment A5 is
running to Knight C7 so we don't have to
worry about that so let's say Rook B1
makes a lot of sense now
yeah rugby one makes sense and then and
then okay Bishop Q4 seems possible but
Bishop e4s always have uh to be made by
Bishop E3 probably
so and now moves like E6 are possible
I don't think white is worse now uh we
yeah Knight B4 probably so yeah yeah
even if you jump and check on D4 white
is completely fine I don't think white
is worse so uh let's go back just to see
if it's possible to find something
different because Knight D4 check now is
another possibility but then the pawn on
E7 is hanging it makes no sense no yeah
rugby one also seems possible so this is
not the same that's not a good choice uh
Bishop G7 Rook B1
maybe Rook d8 makes sense but then of
course I I hated you to allow uh the
Knight to the the route to go to be
seven because here yeah if if black
takes if on after rugby 70 black takes
on
um D5 somehow uh pawns are equal but I
think that would be a little much better
ending for one yeah definitely Magnus
would now want to allow this it only
makes sense if Black's able to secure
the the nylon systems by having the Rook
on C8 but it's one
110p late so I expect again I'm I expect
to move Rook C2 and it will be
interesting to see Magnus reaction yeah
roxy2 has been played and as Magnus is
contemplating his next move looking up
into the distance we are going to take
another short break we'll be back in a
few minutes with more action from
magnus's match and the others don't go
anywhere we will be right back
thank you
[Music]
foreign
okay welcome back to the v-day Worlds
Cup all right now we are monitoring the
situation on Fabiano caruana's board
as everybody is by now aware the players
have been gone for
for over half an hour
and the official broadcast indicates
one zero and fabby's favor we are aware
of what is going on but facts are still
coming in when we have uh the official
report fully out
we will be updating you on exactly
what's going on we we are aware of some
of the facts we're waiting for
everything to come in please be patient
when we have official word
we will relay that to you immediately
but definitely we are we are monitoring
the situation in karwana against figure
on soon
all right in the meantime we can go back
for now to magnus's board
and uh something pretty interesting a
sap and vessel in Magnus has taken on A3
yeah it's a move uh totally I unexpected
for me it looks like the bishop is
trapped on a fee and after Rook A1 it
looks like black is losing a piece
because I don't think uh taking on D5
and playing Knight B4 helps uh because
uh then Rook C4 I think wins the you
know the piece because both the bishop
and the Knights are attacked so that can
be a an option for black so the only way
to to to prevent the losing of the piece
is to play F5 and then of course it's a
complete mess I think the that's what
Magnus for sure has in mind because now
if white takes on H3 then uh that would
be a mistake black takes on e4 both
Knights are attacked and you can't even
move your knight from F3 because then in
the night on D5 would check and then the
Rook uh will fall so I believe after F5
then what white has to do is to go to uh
C7 Maybe
instead of taking the bishop
but then
another option is to of course black can
take on e4 but of course another option
is to play uh Bishop B3 so that's
something I don't it looks very
um
messy many pieces are falling but I feel
that Magnus has calculated correctly
because okay for example I guess white
has to take on E6 but the problem now is
that if they uh after taking on a free
white has a choice either uh we take or
we move our King the problem of taking
is that black is in time to also attack
the Knight and uh this is successful it
looks looks good for black uh it looks
better for black now because Knight C7
attacks The Rook but of course first of
all black can also take give check and
take on C two
uh
but also even moves like Rook C8 look uh
good so yeah taking off three uh with
the pawn shouldn't be a good idea so and
and this is a better version because
um then the king is a better place
but still I don't know what to do for
for
white after Rook F6 yeah and you could
you don't even have to play FG and you
could go F6 out of Knight C7 and keep
even reflecting exactly 95 and everybody
kind of line where and now if Knight E3
I think maybe it was a good idea to to
take uh on G2 uh previously because so
you have Rook G5 yeah then I would have
Rook G5 that's that's
um looks not forced but of course it is
true that maybe white has some chances
for example white can take on E7 then
take on A3 but looks better for black
here but this is the Magnus type of
physician yeah well this is a very very
big Advantage for black I would say
um
but for the moment feels like after five
black has uh
very good chances in the complications
because many things accounting but the
two Bishops and uh also the knights are
not stable as we see you know yeah and I
hate to interrupt this this analysis but
we do want to update everybody we have
more information on the ongoing
situation Maria melanova tweeting from
the tournament Hall spoke to the
organizers officials Fabiano caruano's
opponent uh megaranto's kova test
results came back positive during the
game so the game is forfeited in
Fabiano's favor who was immediately
taken to his hotel room
so that is the situation
um megaranto testing positive during the
game the game was immediately stopped
and presumably
there are doctors involved and Fabio was
taken back to his hotel room that is bad
news
very bad news but uh that is the ongoing
situation that is what we know
oh
that is rough
we'll definitely keep you keep you
posted as we know more about the
situation
it's funny I I was just wondering what
if uh Fabiano test is positive now why
shouldn't them make around to lose the
game because if they both test positive
but maybe the the one who tests positive
first is the the one who loses
no probably Fabi is vaccinated
but that doesn't mean of course that he
can't test positive
um but
I would imagine maybe if I be tested
negative and my grandson tested positive
but we don't know that yeah I agree with
you about some probably
megaranto's test came back and I would
imagine Fabi is is getting tested right
now yeah
um no okay it's not about only about
this game what if they both if both
players stays positive during the game
then it should control uh or I don't
know exactly how the rules are
yeah I mean I they probably didn't
there's probably no
um no clear rules but we have another
update and we thank Maria melanova for
providing them from the tournament all
my garato will remain under a medical
supervision she writes in a second tweet
and it's not known yet whether the
second game will be played if Fabiano is
going to take another test tomorrow he's
showing no symptoms but is expected to
stay isolated in his hotel room
okay so Fabi is getting tested of course
and
imagine his results will yeah
yeah it doesn't feel Pleasant not to
know if you if you're going to have
these symptoms or not yeah good
yeah
so yeah
it's a difficult situation to uh to play
Under you know
yeah for sure so hopefully
hopefully his results come back and
it's just that is the reality of of the
situation we're in so well I think uh
magnus's played the move F5 so soon
we'll see what uh what is happening as I
said it looks uh the first impression it
was good for black
but maybe white uh maybe we missed some
move
so let me ask you this what about
how bad is Rook a3fe
97-97 yeah but it's still pawned down
night
G5 or E5 I'm not sure where the where
the white knight should go but it's I
guess 95.
but yeah but again uh Pawn down and then
rookie five keeps on attacking and uh
even if you survive it definitely it
doesn't look like a way to play for for
white in the future no
yeah I mean Nike for yeah you're right
before maybe threatened some some I mean
the bishop can come out to C3 you know
this is there are dark Square weaknesses
for black here so but it's very obvious
that it's only white who black who plays
for win I mean yeah he doesn't need to
play Rook F5 he can just play any move
and he like Bishop D5 or even A6 let's
say so just Pawn up and it's a solid
Pawn so I don't think it's it's a uh
this good decision for white but but
again I don't see good options because
these complications we were looking at
after Knight C7 okay we didn't look at
the move Bishop B3 which also looks very
good uh but
even taking only for also deserves
attention and from what we saw it looked
like black is completely fine I mean
take yeah the only the only thing maybe
that we missed was that uh after taking
our three king of one something I missed
I think yeah King F1 take on G2 and then
King G1 hiding under the pond that's
right yes and then we after Rook F6 we
keep on attacking black species with uh
Knight C7
and then Rook
um C8 sure the difference now is that
after Rook C8 95 Rook F5 Knight E3
attacks now Rook C8 here and now you
don't have the check from G5 so and
but again the feeling is black is
completely okay I don't know if black is
better but this is something we didn't
look at and it's not completely clear
yet uh and another Cafe
also but are you going to make me I for
the moment it's nothing no I've always
wanted to meet a former world champion
okay okay
uh Knight E6 yeah and then I don't know
uh but it looks it looks good
uh you have to check but again I just
take so I don't think maybe Rook F6 but
I uh the feeling is black black is not
going to win this so rookie three maybe
so somehow I'm hanging
I mean Magnus probably
does not want to go
but you're
just like night before
[Music]
possible now and and even by the way uh
The Rook F6 uh you kind of uh bluffing I
think because you look Rook F6 has no
fit so I I for no reason I defended by
Knight
I mean yeah I guess the night I think uh
record F2 is not hanging so yeah
probably okay for restricting was better
or some some other way but
um for the moment white doesn't have to
play rookie three right another it is it
is also a question what exactly white
should do because uh but again uh many
interesting options and we'll see again
I I think that the bishop B3 was also
interesting uh we that's a move we
didn't even we we considered we didn't
even uh analyze at the very beginning
after after this one yeah it also makes
a lot of sense because we get similar
situations but uh with some extra
options for black because after Rook C3
if you keep on attacking then now I take
on e4 and we get similar situations but
we have also Bishop B2 extra option for
for black
and then again yeah we have the checks
we have the checks and after if you take
on B3 then I take
on a g
on F3 let's say and then maybe on G2
also and of course sometimes I can even
take on C5 with the Bishops so it's
different let's say uh but again I have
the same same moves like Rook d8 another
extra option now Rook C8 can be possible
looks very good for black wow I need an
Excedrin looking at this position she
has so many pieces saying but yeah I
feel like martineovic is okay stuff has
happened
and I know that the the crowd is abuzz
with
with the news from the Fabi game we'll
definitely discuss that a little bit
more but let's let's let's
um take stock of what's happened in this
game first
martinovich did take on E7 wrestling and
then he played Knight D4 so clearly he's
accepted a worse position
and I don't I wouldn't like to have this
against Magnus
yeah he was simply out prepared uh and
we could also see that Magnus played
quickly so he maybe he knew or from or
maybe it was just very easy for him to
to look at uh to calculate all these
lines and of course now black has a
clear Pawn up two good moves Bishop G4 I
don't think it's a bad move uh or Bishop
D5 protecting the porno B7 sometimes and
also the one on E3 uh on uh E4 sorry uh
so both moves should give black solid
advantage
right no this is this is looking very
good for Magnus low on pretty low on
time as well for Sasha Martine image 20
moves to make in 34 minutes yeah it just
seemed like he had you know a better way
to play in the opening and that's just
Magnus for you he does not miss
um he does not miss these chances
so
and from my experience I know Magnus
doesn't miss uh winning positions I mean
he's one of the guys that uh
uh here rarely Miss winning
opportunities I mean he's very good in
uh
collecting uh
points once he has a chance
right
and I switched now to
the girlfriend game which we'll take a
look at but I was just wanted to ask you
sln
um you know if
do you think that all of the players you
know if if Fabi and you obviously hope
he doesn't but if he does test positive
does that mean you know everybody is
going to the tournament is going to be
paused this is obviously an
unprecedented situation so
um
I suppose problem solving will have to
happen
um
well I don't think they will stop the
tournament but uh they for the moment
they only have two as far as I know only
they have two uh positive cases okay and
we don't even know if Levon uh is tested
positive so uh there's nothing to Roy
for the moment but it's also true that
it's only day four you know of the of
the World Cup so it's a worse of
situation that's true it's but again
nobody likes it obviously and yeah
still still
we have to give credit to to the
organizers because it is extremely
difficult to organize
a big big events with so many people you
know and of course we we immediately see
that although I'm sure there are many
many uh measures taken still it's not
possible to
um
to control everything
yeah and even if yeah of course even
vaccines are not 100 percent
effective as we know it's still possible
to test positive so it's not necessarily
good to blame the players that they
might have taken all the necessary
precautions such is the situation
but um yeah we'll keep an eye on that
for you and bring you updates when they
happen but gelfon's position here is
really really interesting and vessel and
I think for us just might be going on to
a crushing Victory here unless I'm
misreading the situation
did he play H5 by the way that was me I
sacrificed this Pawn for him well for
the moment for the moment it's not
winning because if you push H5 I guess
block takes and then Knight H7 uh is not
so good maybe immediately because Black
Hills simply ignore by playing Rook uh
yeah it's all it doesn't look like
winning immediately it looks it is true
it looks very dangerous but I don't
think uh White has to be to decide
immediately whether to play H5 sometimes
it's uh it's more it's better to uh
to prepare and always make your opponent
think about moves like H5 because it
doesn't work that it doesn't always work
uh but I mean uh if you go back from the
starting position another normal movies
to play Knight E5 because sometimes you
can take on F7 you have also extra
option or even moves like King B1 you
know just to see what happens but I
think 95 looks very strong now because
uh we we're just uh
sometimes we have the the option for
Queen B3 and then of course sometimes we
can also take on F7 so it looks to me
like Knight E5 is another good option
and if you remember you're here yeah but
then maybe either I go King B1 or I push
H5 now because now as you see now it
makes a difference 985 page five yes now
it's losing to uh to root H5 so
um so Queen D5 maybe is not such a good
move and I was thinking that if you go
Knight D7 trying to uh exchange couple
of pieces instead of Queen D5 then even
F4 looks very good and there's pawns
defending the night it's beautiful
exactly simply looks uh like white has a
Initiative for free and white and black
would have to lose couple of Tempest to
uh include The Rook from A7 to put it
into play uh you know it looks better
for white but of course uh
um it's not over but again it looks very
promising somehow for white I think
objectively probably the the correct
move after Knight D5 should be Knight D5
not night
um
not night uh D7 and then a very typical
uh move to always consider is Knight H7
yeah absolutely King H7 and then H5
which doesn't mean it doesn't always
work it's also but again it looks so
crushy I mean uh here uh
White's not even down that much material
oh and what about this line vessel in uh
F6 I mean I know you can win with any
way possible I was just thinking about
Rook 8 shade and G7 okay it's not
necessary no but but after Rook h8
obviously black has to go King H7 yeah
yeah sorry repeat I think it moves
looks nice this shouldn't be
it's just Knight F7 Knight F7 H6 is made
or Knight G4 yeah yeah no such positions
you you played to win points not to
paint pictures but you know yelpond is
an amazing shape here and I think we're
all
he's a legend uh we all want him to go
far and he has played 95 that is pure
class it's a natural horoscope improving
uh and waiting for their you know
waiting for the best moment to play H5
right
no he is he is in phenomenal shape here
and idiban I've also been keeping an eye
on that game we're going to take a look
at that but first we're going to take a
quick break when we come back
more action from round two of the feed a
World Cup as a lot of the games are
heating up we might have some results
soon we'll be bringing all of that to
you and more when we come back stay
tuned
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
World Cup we are monitoring two separate
situations those of you just joining the
first is that Grandmaster love on
aronian unfortunately had to Forfeit his
first match game today against Bobby
Chang
he was exhibiting symptoms of fever
earlier and as a precaution he forfeited
today's game he might be playing
tomorrow we will update you on that when
we get more news the second situation
this one very recent according to Maria
emilianova who is at the tournament
scene Fabiano's game against susanta
megaranto was paused in the middle of
the opening
and the news has just come and
megaranto's covet test result came back
positive during the game so uh the game
is forfeited and Fabiano's favor and
both of them uh presumably are being
isolated in uh their hotel rooms and
once again we will bring you more
updates on that situation when we get
them
we are sticking to the facts but I do
our job is to compensate the ongoing
games
uh so we're going to be focusing on that
Magnus has one upon he has good winning
chances it seems against Sasha
martinovich
we've been analyzing that game pretty
extensively wrestling so I think we
should maybe go around a little bit and
check into some of the games we haven't
looked at in a while I would like to
start with alireza faruja who seems to
be not manufacturing too many chances
here against Javier sundarov and that
accelerated Dragon what do you think of
this well definitely it doesn't look so
impressive for white Black's got very
very good
um uh Marazzi
he's attacking out upon on B2 and in
fact it's a bit of a mystery for me
because uh this kind of structures
normally white should be the first one
to put the pawn on B3 his Pawn on B3 and
over it we need to always be the A4 move
the advance of the a pawn with B4 and
that hasn't been done so now uh black
black I don't think black is better but
I I don't see I don't think black has
any problems and even the move like
Bishop D4 doesn't work now that would be
losing after E6 so uh the only
um
the only natural move I mean since move
that move that makes sense is uh either
white can play Bishop C1 which is quite
passive but Rook D1 Rook D from D5 to D2
uh well I just believe that Black's fine
maybe not better yet but uh yeah again
you're right Rook B4 followed by Rook C6
Rook B6 uh attacking the pawn on B2 and
I think black is completely fine and
easy easy moves to play and even if he
doesn't do that it just with
uh with two Bishops it's extremely
difficult to to find uh a winning player
for white so I I again I don't think
black is maybe better but uh black for
sure doesn't have a problem
yeah it's already dragon is annoying and
Ali raza's time
is also a little bit concerning to me 25
minutes or so on his clock for 19 moves
so you know this is uh
this is slightly concerning and I agree
with you probably why it could equalize
but I feel like white has to be more
careful than black this could spiral out
of control for white if he's not careful
yeah simply black doesn't have to do
much he can even wait uh and so I don't
think any uh White has any big plan to
to win I mean even Rook D2 uh and then
as I Rook B4 is good of course but if
you go if you go uh instead of uh rookie
to Bishop C1 you can still do the same
with black you can still double on the B
file and sometimes even uh A3 is
sometimes is a possibility
with the second B3 so there are many
tricks for black I like Black's position
but again it's white should be able to
uh to hold but uh but again even the
move like Knight E6 is already a good
option maybe because they're Knight D4
comes and there are many many uh tricky
tricks for black and somehow white has
to be very careful
indeed and uh we'll keep an eye on this
game another game that we haven't been
watching Alexander fear is pressing
against uh
vidit who is of course the pregame
favorite they had a Petrov it was an end
game
and fear
this bishop B5 boom nice
counter-attacking move
black stroke's got in some trouble
they had a lot of tactics two Bishops
for a rook currently but look at that
pot on D6 it goes forward and vitted is
forced to give up the exchange
after Rook B8 and D.A Queen that's the
line and I think black has probably very
good drawing chances here but maybe
concerning after Rook A1 well I'd be I
believe it should be closer to a draw
for but again it depends uh
let's say of course once if white is
able to exchange the pair of Rooks then
of course White's Advantage would be
much bigger than now but uh for the
moment uh let me see
um
of course also sometimes white has to be
careful with not allowing the advance of
the deep Pawn so if imagine black goes
something like King F6 we did it would
sometimes uh help the advance of the
pawn I think black should have enough
compensation uh but again
he he has to be also careful because if
especially if the pawn a7's loss then uh
the white eighth Pawn can immediately be
also very quick
so yeah 586 which fix the pawn on A7 and
then maybe get the Rook around to B7
something like that yeah but I I believe
black has to be active you can just wait
because if you wait uh and exchange a
pair of Rooks then I'm afraid that could
be a technically lost position so uh one
general rule it almost always works
is that
um the advantage of uh The Rook against
a bishop or Knight in this case a bishop
is much bigger if you have a a pair of
an extra pair of Rooks so it means that
black has to keep the Rooks now right on
the board and to be active
yeah for sure an exchange would be the
bishop would be incapable of handling
uh the The Rook whereas blackstroke now
gives
significant trying chances so yeah but
look for example maybe a good option for
black is to place the root on A5 that's
one uh and and it's good also that uh
the bishop protects all all the pawns so
you put your Pawn on H5 and The Rook on
A5 which means white has to
play A3 but then it will be difficult to
activate the Rook from A1 so definitely
black has good drum chances but uh we'll
see again keep the Rooks on the board
never change them
indeed and uh we'll keep an eye on fear
but it is also low on time I've been
surfing some of the games and another
one that I want to take a look at
is Jeffrey Jean's game against Victor
mikolevsky which is only 13 moves in but
already an incredibly sharp position
nikolevsky of course
he's a very strong GM and Jeffrey is one
of the brightest stars of American chess
what is going on here was an English
opening
kind of a you know sort of normal
English that became very very sharp
Jeffrey
C5 Bishop E6 and Jeffrey going for the
long castle and michalevsky striking in
the center with D4 this does look good
for white but I'm not sure what to make
of this very good let me see okay of
course first of all we have to look at
is the Knight takes C6 because this and
then of course white also has a very
good interesting option to suck a pawn
with Knight D5
so we already have two uh two good moves
of course Knight B5 is maybe interesting
sometimes or 94 but but 94 is not an
option because it means you have to take
with the Knight so you're losing your
attacking options so you could also play
96 here oh you're right that's true of
course of course so maybe yeah it looks
very good for white but because this is
a positional Advantage
um and the other yeah and the other
option is to sack a pawn by Knight D5
and then if you take with the with the
bishop because and The Rook uh then H4
is followed and then Bishop C4 comes
next I don't know moves like Knight H7
F7 also deserves some attention and
Bishop C4 now so it looks promising for
white but again yeah uh Knight takes E6
followed by 94 or 94 followed by Knight
E6 uh both moves looks very good very
good
right 94. 94 and now 96 and this kind of
position just looks nasty Black's
position starts to collapse well except
I don't know if a move like Knight F2
works but I don't believe it's a good
one I mean Knight F2 instead of
taking on on E6 I don't think it's a
good one
right I mean it just looks like White's
got to have something here maybe an idea
yeah and 91 yeah
then I guess I'd be seven
yeah this this has to be good for white
I would imagine
[Music]
yeah right but still it's just a pawn up
somehow
right makes makes a lot of sense
um
if if Queen C7
take on D1 take on D4 out the pawn good
position yeah
we we have our first decisive result of
the day which is that aliban has
expected in very very convincing and
and nice fashion has defeated uh Delgado
Ramirez
so I think this is our first decisive
result well Queen H7 at the end very
beautiful
um simple but beautiful Bishop Queen H7
takes takes King h8 and Rick f8 is going
to be mate so Oscar nadiban
he's won his first one
and uh he's up one zero
all right so let's check back into my
midiaros game which probably is going to
end in a draw and if so that is a big
result for Cree core holding chakra art
to a draw with the black bases I don't
think black has any serious chances for
an advantage here but black is drawing
from a position of strength it seems
yeah yeah that is true
um looks very cool uh but of course
uh
probably he's considering move like
Knight
um
C5 I think and then uh if that happens
then I don't think moves like Knight D6
makes sense because why somehow it's not
clear what exactly white want to do and
F6 could even give an advantage because
the pawn on E5 is weak I mean black has
Knight D3 next and you can't uh you
can't take on F6 and somehow moves like
Knight B5 they're not really it doesn't
look like white is playing for win so
after Knight C5 I expect a handshake or
or drawing right so
I don't know how many moves have been
played 27 so they're they're probably
going to make a couple more it means
they need at least 30 moves uh but
Knight C5 looks like the The Logical you
know more
that draw equalizes because
um I don't know moves like a G5 I don't
think it makes sense to try and in fact
a draw is a very good result uh
especially if you're tired you know and
I don't know if if
is filling the jet lag already
but you know when we have all these news
about uh
[Music]
the pro problems with the positive tests
I've been thinking that I've been quite
lucky that in most of my uh the
Championships World Championship
the matches or the World Cup and all the
Cycles I've been played most of the
times I've never had serious health
problems but of course the longer it
takes the probability for something
something to go wrong of course
increases and that's one of the
drawbacks of the long matches I believe
that some external factors
become important you know as a health
health condition of course becomes much
more important than in shortened matches
because the probability that someone
gets sick increases of course and then
of course uh in in matches in fact of
course the the quality of the team
becomes to play uh more important role
than in shorter matches the narcot
systems for example
yeah I mean all of the you know with
fatigue adding up your immune system
is is a little bit more compromised as
the matches go on so that's I think
that's a great point
um we also have very interesting
position
in the game between evich and Vallejo I
think Vallejo
uh something disastrous happened to Paco
Vallejo who of course is the favorite in
this game
and in this match yeah
you've sacked a piece at some point yeah
195 which is which you know that idea
exists
but it seems like he didn't really get
any compensation for it no that's not I
mean it's a very typical Pawn uh peace
sacrifice but apparently in this
position he didn't something went wrong
because I don't know about move like
Bishop D6 no it looks like a good pin so
uh what's wrong with uh with I thought
maybe work age for might be a good idea
the the bishop on F1 is protected but
okay if you go Queen H4 of course if I
exchange all I take on H4 then of course
I'll get mated that's a good point right
right Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen
takes and queen G7 made threat no this
is simply P sub so maybe he missed
something like that could be but but
anyway I think that's what he that has
to play he plays
because maybe uh there could be some
move after Luke H4 a move I don't find
for the moment but could it be that
um
let me see because
well if you take with the bishop and
queen B6 check it's in play Losing
because
so it makes absolutely no sense and for
the moment we don't see a good move for
black
um
yeah image is thinking in this position
I mean this is a key position both of
them are quite low on time
but if white finds Rook H4 this might be
game over like literally yeah the most
white can do is to go uh queen bee free
attacking the pawn on B5 on D5 it also
makes sense we it's a way to unpin and
then also looks good I don't see uh
immediately what can black do
uh because Knight F6 is very passive and
uh if you take with a knight
if you're taking the night then then
Bishop E5 and just
just a piece for no compensation for
almost nothing yeah it takes of course
there's 25 with the fork so this might
be a pretty significant upset as if it's
is thinking in this position he's got
plenty of time we will keep an eye on
image against Vallejo yeah I mean uh I
when I looked uh quickly at the moves it
feels wrong when Black Goes uh Queen B6
and then Queen A5 somehow that shouldn't
be the way because uh there are many
ways many positions when white
exchanges it's a black sacrifice on E5
but of course always the greatest of B6
and it's a better place but uh now of
course I think Paco uh either he missed
something or or he felt that uh he's
getting uh outplayed completely and he
because white has a lot of space here so
if black doesn't do anything quickly
then uh White should be better but I
probably F5 was better it looks ugly or
or even C4 I don't know but the way he
played maybe he simply missed something
yeah yeah no yes
definitely he looks like he's in trouble
yeah because he could have taken another
Pawn on F3 but of course then uh still
his pieces are not
um
developed and then white would still be
much better
yeah and that H6 spawn always guarantees
attacking chances related to Queen G7
mate okay so on our camera well now out
of the corner of your eye you can see my
audio body
trying hunkering down defending against
mvl who just seems to be having a very
smooth game
this is not looking like what elshon
signed up for when he played one E4 yeah
I mean it looks much much better for
black uh because I just simply don't see
a way for white to defend the C4 pawn
and
yeah and and it's not it's a B3 is not a
move that white wants to play no also I
mean the only way double on the eight
file and yeah
so and and again white has it's not
really a contemplate if you prepare E4
F4 with white because then the black
Bishop from G7 would uh enter and that's
a a very strong piece you shouldn't open
the diagonal and again but if you just
stay I think then black would simply
have a very very serious advantage and
of course we have to never forget about
Pawn sacrifices like B3
for example move like Rook C2 run
immediately to B3 yeah that's horrible
for white it's immediately losing so
so you have to try to block the position
but uh I just don't see uh
a good way to pre to defend the C4 Pawn
finally maybe what white has to play is
to just stay play B3 and move the king
to d one
so B3 here maybe maybe not immediately
maybe maybe but at some point yeah and
then try to run to D1 with the King and
TR and escape and block the block the
position but of course feels like much
better for black
feels better yeah we can see a nice view
there Alshon he is struggling he's not
happy
and uh MBL is just so good in these
Sicilian positions say he has no equal
in in these types of situations all
right so but again but maybe he he has
to do it now in fact because uh if you
wait maybe white black could play uh B3
immediately with
with and then opening the queen side is
not a good idea and of course if if you
go A3 then Rook C8 wins the pawn uh so
if he has to do it maybe if he wants to
uh execute this plan he has to do it now
right but again black is better of
course
yeah yeah undoubtedly mvl is is in
control let's take a look at the
um ladies section and see how
how that is faring yeah we had a draw in
the field is against tanzongi game the
top seed Alexander garajana is facing
off against so her jonova you're
refreshed to get the latest here
and it just seems like Alexandra's
firmly in control after Knight F4
yeah it looks very good for black I mean
especially I like the Knight on D5
and then Pawn structure is very good The
Rook on C6 is a bit of plane of course
Knight F4 followed by Knight H3 wins one
Pawn but
black doesn't even have to do it
immediately I mean first we have to find
a good place for the black queen and
it's not so easy and not only H3 uh is
all an option but also Knight G2 is
another uh interesting idea and then of
course you can also go Bishop G8 Bishop
D5 and take on G2 so I believe that
black should be very close to winning
here
yeah this is a I mean just nothing
created here
by white on the queen side I mean she
has a good Rook on C6 but that's about
it so Alexandra is definitely in charge
um Jennifer you against Abba kosova
uh who is another pre-tournament
favorite looks like Dinara is
also in very good shape here after
something like Knight C4
yeah it's a better better Pawn structure
uh so endings is better but of course uh
it's a question if white will be able to
advance this Pawn on a four of course
white is better but I'm not sure about
the move 94 maybe there could be a
different moves because the Knight on A5
is also sometimes in trouble so but
again it's very typical let's say 94 you
take Queen takes C4 and then uh not only
of course I'm attacking the room but
sometimes Queen before sometimes because
if I if I move my roots there uh
right uh but but of course uh Rook d8 we
can't take on C5 because of Rook C8 so
but of course I I guess just move like
uh B3 makes a lot of sense but uh well
but still look uh I think it's a better
if better chances for black if he tries
to exchange the Rooks maybe play Queen
D7 instead of Rook D5 and the look for
some activity Maybe
I don't know
oh yeah trying for something only five
here does look good for white
or even Bishop G5 because of course
with Queen said uh maybe bishop G5 makes
sense sometimes I don't know
but of course white is better yeah
yeah and sort of another in this
position the pawn is very quick yeah
yeah that apron is just rushing forward
so we'll keep an eye on that one as well
and it seems like animals who took the
second seat is
facing off against abrahamian they've
got a classic French position here where
at first I thought white was much better
due to her Knight on E5 but now I'm not
so sure because lots of pressure down
the sea file classic win-hour Pawn
structure and maybe black can take on C4
on D4 if you're in untapped or White's
Pawns
yeah but I I expect white to take with
the queen maybe because then even though
you
you take consider maybe Rook C1 or queen
queen or maybe Queen B6 followed by
Queen D6 uh somehow but it should be
black should be able to hold I I
believed because uh the Knight it is
true that the Knight looks very nice on
um on E5 but maybe the pawn weaknesses
compensate and of course for the moment
the bishop is uh restricting the White
Knight and doesn't look like
um
big big trouble for the moment uh but
yeah I it's critical of course to take
on D4 right yeah I mean it seems like
Tata needs to be
needs to be very careful here and she's
got some problems to solve but well I
don't end up being a close game another
option white can for white is to take
with the pawn and then after Queen takes
C2 maybe exchange
and then I you know for example go
something for Rook okay
and try to mate if you go to H7 then
somehow play Rook B7 and
bring the other Rook to a to A7 to A8 it
could be made so it's another option uh
so should be somehow still good for
black but it's not guaranteed
uh I think maybe black
is able to somehow save the game
but it's not so easy maybe I don't know
I mean what I'm looking now is that
moves like room D1 Rook D2 imagine Rook
C1 and Rook C8 and then
but yeah Rook D2 Rook C1 Rook Rook takes
D4 Rook C8
and maybe Rook E4 attacking yeah this is
forcing the camera and then and then F4
forces black to take on E5 and go to uh
H5 so two we have one pawn and then the
king is safe already going to F5 maybe
black holes but yeah definitely
um definitely
so Tata is thinking here she's down to
19 minutes
black has to be active because if white
consolidates then uh soonerly something
might happen you know uh big
and also the pawn on Basics is weak uh
yeah I think she has to go to to take on
uh D4
yeah yeah definitely it seems like
otherwise why it's going to consolidate
her positional Advantage before we we
take a break let's come back to the open
section and see
how our world champion is doing Magnus
seems to be making a lot of progress
toward
um converting this advantage against
martinovich as he's got white really
pushed back against the wall here
yeah it's not only that it looks it is
probably uh technically winning
but of course it's even more difficult
to defend over the board because again
one mistake uh from White could be just
like the final and then of course black
and never make a big mistake somehow and
you have to keep your Rooks always on
the a file because you it stops the
advance of the a pawn but of course the
black king can come so I don't know
maybe what white should do is to press
play G3
and then Exchange
on D3 maybe because
because taking with the pawn is not that
dangerous in fact so but of course you
can do that immediately because the pawn
on G2 is hanging so now take and then
probably take with the Rook not with uh
you know
um not with the pawn because that pawn
it it is a postpone but at the same time
it can be weak so I would take with the
rook and and
I don't know for example Rook D1
uh Ruby free maybe and then
and then still we have this problem with
the a pawn
uh trying to push their pawn and check
on D6 it's only one check it it doesn't
really uh
change much so and now we have a problem
with uh with a pawn so I would take with
the Rook but we'll see what happens uh
anyway
position is very ugly for white yeah
extremely and Magnus wins these games
all the time I mean he you know nothing
is guaranteed but 10 minutes also for
Martinez for 12 moves one just gets the
sense that
that he's lost control of the game okay
we're gonna take a quick break
when we come back we're already getting
in some getting some results uh two and
a half hours after the start of the
round Magnus trying to convert an
advantage we'll be bringing all of that
action to you after another short break
we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
Worlds Cup presented by chess.com those
of you just joining we are monitoring
two separate situations the first being
that Lavon aronian has forfeited today's
game
due to symptoms of fever
that he exhibited earlier uh whether he
will play tomorrow and try to tie his
match against Bobby Chang that remains
to be seen and we will update you when
we have more information the second
situation of course concerns Fabiano
caruana's game against megaranto during
the games the Santa magrando's kova test
came back positive
um he was forfeited immediately and in
fabi's favor of course and they were
both taken to their respective hotel
rooms we are keeping tabs on that
situation as well
and we'll bring you the facts as it
continues to unfold okay so right now
we're watching the games from round two
game one Magnus Carlson
pressing a big advantage against Sasha
martinovich he is very likely to win
this game
we have a couple of results Alexander
fear
um was unable to produce any kind of
chances against vidit
and Vaseline played Rook A8 which I
guess you called it he didn't watch that
deep on
and he had to give up his a pawn for the
d-pawn
and he just didn't create any chances
here at all vidit has to be counting his
life is lucky stars here a little bit
well yeah okay this this looks like uh
uh very equal now of course so
um but again I've been during the break
I've been look looking at some of the
positions and many interesting happening
for example uh could you show uh the
game I think uh that could be a big
surprise that uh David Anton is in
trouble with the white pieces he's a
rating favorite against idani and he's
in serious trouble it looks like it's a
naming where where uh Black's Pawn is
advancing also to
to it's Advanced to the to D2 so
uh White is in trouble in fact here
um that's one of the positions where the
pawn is really strong and there's no way
uh to stop it for the moment
um I don't know for example uh what
black can do it's a simple plan that
black has imagine you play something
like H6 what they did to uh
make a place for for the king and then
next move could be Rook C1
if you play F3 or F4 we did to come with
the King uh I mean Black is Black to
move I think no I think it's white too
because 1997 yeah but that was a mistake
I believe that because Black's plan
should be to play uh I think H6 was
quite good followed by Rook C1 the other
C8 and the other Rook to C8 no because
uh F3 for example C1
yeah but here maybe Rook D2
uh uh you're right in fact uh ah the
idea of the move Rook uh
D7 of course is the The Rook is now
protected uh yeah but the thing is the
A3 is Big so maybe it's time for white
to go A5 but no but now works C1 yes
yeah
so I don't know but Rook C1 is Rook B6
for the moment
so it's getting mated no so that's what
that was the idea of the move uh A6 so
this is mate as far as I see yeah sorry
okay one just gonna show that there's
this background black spot was on H6
here so we need everything would be
different we need a bond on uh on H6 uh
but the plan is to play Rook C1 with the
Rook uh defend it of course you're right
and then if Rook from B2 goes to B1 then
we double on the C file change on B1 and
the the new rook and uh play again
um not not of course in this position
but I mean that was the plan so that was
the reason I think Rook H6 was more
precise than root D7
uh because here A5 is uh an extra extra
option for white no right and here of
course A5 there's absolutely nothing
because the A3 is no longer weak exactly
exactly H6 was much stronger
um followed by Rook D7 and Rook C1 and
the other Rook I think uh but while in
the game of course uh after the move
Rook D7
um
after The Rook D7 then A5 looks much
stronger now
yeah so right now uh the lead on tone is
contemplating his next one he's got
seven minutes for 13 moves also that's
unpleasant
well I don't know what why black wanting
G2 King G2 well okay that makes sense I
mean the idea is I guess for C1 wait
what is the idea Rook C1 Rook B1 yeah
but then Rooks is seven yeah yeah yeah I
mean no this I don't know what what if
Black Goes uh H5 or H6 H5 I think is
even better sometimes because it gives
the extra option for Bishop G4 check
maybe so I I don't know right I don't
care I don't I don't care that much
about the pawn on H5 uh right here
you're welcome to take it I mean Rook C1
even helps black so yeah but again H5 or
H6 it's useful and then we have the same
plan
um right and I don't know if King F3
going to e302 E2 is there should be
something somehow uh should be that easy
for white to to get closer to the depot
with the King
right yeah and of course and of course
uh David also is very much lower in time
so at this point some kind of a surprise
although of course they're both over 26
600 but uh David he's uh okay also with
white of course and he was supposed to
be the favorite in this match definitely
definitely yeah
and by the way
um David paravian
has defeated Alexander onishek with
black in their first game
sadly for Alexander just unable to
to
um
survive in these tactics we had some
sort of a slav in 94.
ownership's position starting to
collapse here after BC Knight dc5 yeah I
think he's just blundered because first
of all the move H3 looks like complete
waste of time because what has happened
is that if you see the game 94 was
played and white played Knight F3 which
me but somehow my question is why why
not to immediately if you can't stop the
move 94 then you better play Knight F3
immediately and not H3 no and then right
because anyway uh it's very obvious that
Black's move the good move for Blackest
Night
um
Knight E4 and now of course you have
more options I mean if Black Goes 90 for
now I would never play H3 myself no that
I would be looking for right I would be
looking for some more useful move like
if I and of course I I would protect my
opponent on C5 if you want you can even
play Knight B3 now uh somehow anything
looks better than what then what
happened in the game yeah because
Alexander he he's just trying to play
like this but now yeah
yeah that's a it's insane crushing move
he's just missed some tactics obviously
yep and
um paravian went on to win okay
obviously extra material and gave up the
queen for two Rooks and two pawns
winning position he converted it also
for the same beat Axel Bachmann which is
a pretty much expected result for the
save over 2 700 incredibly strong with
white pieces he played a nice game let's
have a quick look at berev's game
against arientari it looks very easy
position
okay so you have a clear French
well the Rave is down to almost six
minutes and it looks uh very much in
trouble for him because okay he can of
course take
um
what is the idea
I guess it's Knight H4 yeah I think now
there should be some my feelings there
should be something for white uh okay D4
probably but the D4 of course it's not
it's not a place I want to allow uh the
king for example I mean Knight E4 comes
so and what about yeah what about Queen
E5 is it mate do you see do you see
anything really if I'm I'll give you a
check and then you move if you move
Queen to D3 then I still have a move
like 97 so for the moment it's not yes
uh but yeah but I'm looking at it
but in fact it's white to move so
something has happened I think or maybe
yeah
uh Bishop A4 was played and that's a
move we didn't consider but that gives
the option for white to go Queen G7 and
uh then uh of course uh here black looks
fine Queen G7 takes six I think G7 but
but at least white White's not uh piece
down no I mean I just removed my Bishop
to D3 and it falls are equal so
um for the moment of course so yeah okay
but Rook hate maybe even this doesn't
look so convincing to for for black I
think because I could take if I want to
and then maybe
to give another check
and then Rook H5 protects the pawn so if
I'm able to also play
um Knight to E2 then white shouldn't be
losing for sure I don't think white is
losing here uh but that's that's another
option and that is only if of course uh
White uh wants to uh to play Queen G7
but maybe Terry is looking for something
else maybe he simply wants to uh to keep
playing with Queen G4 Maybe
he did play where did he play in fact
maybe black can also take with the Rook
on G7 because then anyway because the
big the the bishop is attacked I don't
think you have mate you you can open uh
somewhere you can go to D3 with check
but no more than that no and then of
course The Rook is already attacking the
pawn on G2 no he took with the King yeah
it's solid remember Bishop D3 that's all
probably going to happen yeah I don't
know about moves like uh what about Rook
H5 immediately I mean if you go Rook H5
um it's another option I don't like it
for white but it's maybe it's a
possibility yeah I mean
or maybe even or maybe even Rook H4
because then I can also check from G4
until today so it's it's an adoption
look at that idea yeah no this is this
is quite Dynamic for for tari and it
could go either way this is a very
interesting game now I I want to bring
to you another
I'm thinking yeah Rook H4 looks very
interesting that is true because then if
you take with the Knight maybe I just
take it and then check but looks fine
for black for the moment
but there are there are tricks there are
tricks for sure yeah and barev he's a
Legend So experienced we'll see if he
manages to survive this position against
a young Ari and tari we have a couple
more results Alexander pretge and vasib
Dora Bailey Drew their game
um I think Vladimir molokov
um but also very experienced Jim is
about to defeat daniele bocaturo
Italian number one
in a very sharp game and he's got a
devastating attack going on the seventh
ranked vessel and we this is a game we
haven't been looking at but block of is
really strong yeah but it's also true
that's probably the moment it's what uh
Bishop takes H7 it's not mating yet so
Rook G7 is the threat yeah it is true so
I mean okay uh
what if so what if I take it's so I can
take on B1 because Queen D1 Queen D5
mates no questions
yeah also yeah you're right so uh for
the moment it looks of course Queen H6
is the only way to stop someone yeah but
then okay seven I think yeah yeah it
looks winning of course when F6 and oh
look at this Rook G1 yeah Magnus just
has finished by the way I'm looking for
cameras yeah for sure yeah I I I believe
he's one because uh I I don't think he
would let his he would not offer a draw
in this position let's just put it that
way
but why would Martinez just really
quickly I wanted to show this line in
this position what about Rook G5 and
Rook h8 double Rook sack and rookie and
queen H7 is made so that's one way this
game could end Perez spawns and grishook
making a very uh colorless draw also
grishook with the black pieces he wasn't
trying too hard to to win well it's a
practical you know right exactly by the
way I I I was looking at the game of um
between one of the future future
opponents of
of Magnus uh it was Alex aiev against
voitashek and it looked like alexef had
a very solid positional Advantage after
the opening they had a they played some
night off and it looked like white was
better
and by the way the position of Martian
which resigning was this one I think he
was just he lost hope I mean Magnus will
win this
and maybe I mean he should have probably
played but it's easy to say that I mean
no no but the black's plan is very easy
because he attacks the pawn on C4 or he
tries to push his Pawn on A5 and at some
point you can't defend both you know so
but yeah it's uh and of course it's a
it's a very this annoying and it's a
torture to defend a position like this
so no I understand
completely yeah yeah yeah for sure now a
couple more results uh mostly expected
uh we have yuyan ghee beating cartridge
very convincingly
on both with the white pieces alexenko
and krasenko made a draw Auntie breakage
uh the Croatian GM defeating 2700 Yuri
like she devastated him uh with white so
creeper rich girl have to come back
tomorrow I uh yakuboyev and Navara
making a draw a fair defeating Bachmann
so we got a lot of results pouring in
let's have a look at that Alex save game
you referenced uh vessel in
I'm going to find it and just also Hari
and bakra has have a really interesting
position
but uh first I want to take a look at
the void to check
shurov is also playing
by the way yeah
you have so many interesting games
to track everything so many things has
changed since the last time I looked at
but okay still we have this
um ending and it looks better for white
because of the pawn weakness on A5 but
certainly I think blacks done some
progress maybe it's still bad but uh
because but what I looked with couldn't
abort it looked pretty passive for black
and now uh of course for example if
white uh
place I if you if white plays Knight C4
I think uh the better uh it's it's a
good option for black to try to maybe to
suck a pawn by playing A4 and taking on
A5 is uh only upon as I said I mean King
G8 and then I think uh black would have
some counter play and uh it's not so
easy to win this position
yeah that's my fizzle out fizzle out
into a draw we've got a lot of Pawn
exchanges that might happen here and as
you indicated the king is perfectly
saved here for a voice check but of
course white is better I mean we there's
no no doubt about it and uh
um but again uh we'll see we'll see uh
there are many options of course white
can also take on e4 uh and to to to take
the knights to to E4 and then maybe
check and then we try to win the pawn on
25 without allowing the pawn on opponent
lies Advance because also day five point
is all it's also weak so right I mean
check on D7 and then maybe Rook D5 makes
it also yeah I get the king back and
yeah definitely white is hunting for an
advantage here yeah
yeah for example but again it's not so
easy
of course
maybe white will win a pawn but will it
will not uh be so easy to it will not be
the end of the game
right for sure and um
all right so um mommy Diary of we'll
bring you that game in just a second I
want to take a look at Alexi shirov's
position and Boris galfa I mean but yeah
there are so many interesting games
right now we I mean it is impossible to
keep track of everything you know saren
and uh making a very uneventful draw as
well
typical wow typical Sheriff I'm only
sure up could have this yeah it smells
better for white of course but uh
and in fact with five minutes to to go I
don't know which is the opening looks
like some kind of a slaps love Yeah
but uh looks awesome yeah typical
Sheriff yeah
um very nice looks like he was in
trouble at some point but
this looks yeah
but Jeremy Keith I don't know about E3
now I don't know about Queen takes that
far I think Queen E4 here maybe it was
better okay but still of course Knight
D3 it's not
um the end
yeah but now it looks like shirov is a
good amazing position much better for
white yeah but of course I don't know uh
the only way to survive for black is if
black is able to somehow exchange the
Queens but for the month I don't see how
maybe Queen what about Queen G4 now
we'll take on H7
yeah so you know okay I see yeah and
then take and queen G7 back maybe but
yeah it looks bad it looks bad even an
end game honestly looks uh quite
promising with such domination
definitely definitely yeah looks I mean
and you don't have to look very deep in
the lines just look at the Rook Rook on
A8 and Bishop on CA so that would be a
miracle and also with four minutes to go
to uh which four minutes left it's uh
very difficult to believe that black can
survive this game
yeah yeah I agree completely and sure
off as a lot of fans it's the end but
Crow by the way defeating Ravi hariya
who is who defeated dragons have in the
first round but Crow he has been playing
really he's been playing well recently
so solid so experienced and uh crushing
Victory here with the black pieces in a
position that looked quite equal at some
point so he yeah I mean in a way it
makes sense uh it's almost impossible to
win in the opening with black so first
you go go through equality and
eventually white makes a mistake no but
uh well but I think at Yang has been
working and helping Maxim so for sure he
has a lot of knowledge
you know and uh especially in the
opening and he's very experienced so
it's not in fact it's not a surprise
that he he will he has this very good
chances to go to the second round
winning with black the first game is uh
I mean
maybe 90 possibilities yeah especially
some some uh rating matchup like that
okay of course have made a draw
uh Quezada and Hare Krishna made a draw
so lots of draws at the top
um as some of the high higher rateds you
know not minding draw with the black
pieces I'm looking now it's the cameras
and I just uh could you just show a bit
again uh Maxim's position
[Music]
against uh elshon
yep I'm finding that one there it is oh
all right yeah
somehow things that I predicted has
happened and now yeah exactly right I I
somehow I see why it's done some
improvement and
if
the Knight is extremely well placed on
e4 I don't know how that has happened in
fact I I imagine if I believe what has
happened is that uh
black simply made some positional
mistake okay rookie one I don't think
it's uh I think what D5 and D5 I don't
like maybe it was it looks fancy it
looks fancy but it gives the E4 Square
for the night exactly I would try to
double uh double on the a file and
Advance with the Rooks I think yeah I
think you're right on the money here
this just seems like it gives right
prospects for the night and even I think
MBL fell in love with the defile getting
open but it's hard for him to get a rook
to the D file in a timely fashion
exactly he does it's not so dangerous I
mean King can go up to probably King E1
is better so that you don't have Rook a
two check yeah I mean somehow the knight
from D2 uh May uh found a perfect place
perfect square for and I don't of course
black shouldn't be worse but uh at the
same time I don't I mean okay it may it
is logical to open the position whilst
you have two Bishops but the Knight on
D2 was so passive and now it has this
Square on e4 and exactly and then you
have the other Bishop on G7 completely
closed so uh again I I think
maxims that made some mistake by playing
D5 or maybe he missed some tactics maybe
he had some idea in mind but now looks
like black is a white is not in uh in
trouble
um structure for white uh postpone
control the D file
yeah and of course the bishop of G5 is
also perfectly placed also and then move
40 has been made of course I'm supposed
to remain unbiased but Alshon lives in
in North Carolina he's
I might see him around all the time I
know he was preparing very very
diligently for the World's Cup he's he's
doing better than he was let's see if he
can hold it together against mvl
um all right we are going to go on a
quick break when we come back more
results are coming in lots of time
scrambles lots of actions do not go
anywhere we will be back with more
action from round two of the fide World
Cup presented by chess.com we'll be
right back
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Worlds Cup box Champs is back on August
29th POG jumps four returns with some
familiar faces Mr Beast and Ludwig
reappear for their shot of Glory
presented by coinbase box Champs 4
promises to be the biggest brightest and
best POG Champs yet so don't miss out on
any of the action that is coming your
way starting August
29th now those of you just joining us
for round two of the fide World Cup we
have two unfortunate situations that we
are monitoring first of all of
honoronian has missed today's game
against Bobby Chang
due to concerns over his health he was
experiencing symptoms of a fever and as
a precaution he has forfeited today's
game he might return tomorrow the second
piece of news is that during Fabiano's
game against Wisconsin megaranto
megaranzo
um tested positive for Coba that game
was paused and forfeited in Fabiano's
favor both players are being currently
isolated in their respective hotel rooms
and we will bring you more updates
as that situation continues to unfold
there's a lot of situations that aren't
folding on all of the boards as we're
getting a lot of the results coming in
lots of time scrambles and some of the
top games are heating up as well uh
Vaseline Anish giri seems to have very
good winning chances he's played a
smooth endgame game against savchenko
and things are looking kind of grim for
black hair well definitely uh Anish got
a very very very serious uh
positional advantage in this ending so
his last move after F6 he could have
played Bishop A4 instead he decided to
exchange the pause and I expect him to
play G4 next and by uh by this
he would have uh securing a very strong
pass-born H5 on H on each file and it
looks very very difficult position for
black not only because uh
the postpone is uh dangerous but because
black has to waste time to protect his
A7 Pawn so he can't really stop
immediately uh the pawn on uh the H4
Pawn with Rook C8 because then uh Bishop
takes A7 is very strong it means that
again it's not completely over but Anish
is close to winning I think he has
fairly good chance to win this game I I
believe uh
yeah just his play seems so crisp
recently
um just just confident
and uh yeah this is suction cup tied up
hand and foot here and it just
seems like Gary's gonna go on to win
this
whoa um for sure for sure fairly good
chances to win
and of course easy way easy uh easy game
uh time Advantage so pretty good chances
to to win this game
indeed okay let's check back into the
game between okay I don't think we'll
have to spend a long time on this game
jibava and stringland just seems like
it's heading toward a draw Sam doing a
good job holding together a position
that at some point seemed a little bit a
little bit iffy but
Sam doing a good job here
okay so this is probably just going to
be a drop it is very practical to take
on B6 I mean uh very big Advantage time
Advantage for black so it makes no sense
to play for win for white and if and of
course for sure white is not uh better
because both phones were attacked not
only the one on H5 or on D5 but also the
on H5 so uh simplifications make sense
and then a white has to play for for
draw and I don't think uh they should
play many more moves
yep
all right and let's check into the
Google game which is heating up as well
cash is has one minute for 10 moves but
seems like he's on the move here what is
going on is flag of Knight A5
oh
yeah I guess Queen C5 as possible yes
yes so first things that uh come in mind
is uh when whether we can attack or not
so yeah
um of course this is possible so now
unfortunately
queen of f8 is not possible because the
bishop is on d7's Candy uh and if we
exchange if we exchange uh if we take
the the knights the the rook and then
Queen takes A3 probably it should be
around equal I think but of course it's
very very massive big I don't I don't
find a good place now for the bishop for
example Bishop Dixie immediately loses
to Queen B2 and Bishop D4 to queen to
queen uh B4 wow so Bishop F6 is first I
think yes but the idea
mm-hmm yeah then you have to go to H4
but again it looks a bit dangerous still
afternoon close
Queen B2 maybe uh followed by E6 so I
don't know if that's losing but uh but
again maybe Knight A5
maybe Knight A5 was not the best move
um right but still yeah you're right
that's still an option uh what else
could black do uh what if
okay another option could be just to go
Rook A1 I don't it looks a bit weird
that's true but but my idea is to to
play Knight A5 after the move uh Fe
e say that again which move I mean to go
Rook a one okay one I don't like it but
could be an option because if you take
now Knight A5 wins no so if you take on
E5 the Knight A5 no the idea is that if
the queen moves then you just take the
rook and then you take on B7 yes
but even that's not so clear because uh
I'm thinking about moves like Rook D7
but it seems that it's just losing to
Knight C4 Rook F7 King G8 so we yeah so
we are losing uh too many Rooks
we can't we can't uh have both Rooks so
uh but uh that's but of course after
Rook A1 white shouldn't take maybe on E5
exchanging The Rook makes a lot more
sense and then uh the bishop would be
misplaced but yeah once again black is
having trouble with his miners exactly
but maybe it works somehow I don't know
uh maybe move because the king is still
exposed it's you can play most like
Bishop uh Knight B6 with white because
Bishop moves to E6 and then you made it
on
do you want sometimes uh
so what I'm saying is it could be still
good for black I don't think white is
black is better but uh
uh again
yeah we'll keep an eye on on bhukesh's
efforts to continue the initiative he
does have a minute do Bob getting low on
time as well she's undoubtedly
calculating Knight A5 I have two results
for you Alexi sheriff is expected
has gone on
to beat Yara subject but this is not the
position
uh the position the final position is
Checkmate on the board
and yes wait wait vessel and Yara saw
played E5 oh are you kidding me but it's
not that lost he can play Queen F5 he
can continue to fight yeah that's true
well what is that
oh my lands it happens it happens okay
it does happen but yeah man no in fact
it was a very good positional movie in
fact E5 you know because it's odd
structure yeah
yeah it's a small problem I mean who
cares in Checkmate yeah
yeah well Galaxy sure I've beaten
well but I mean the
SE that Queen A5 is still lost because
uh even if I change and take Bishop F4
looks pretty much yeah difficult
position for black I mean yeah I agree I
agree he could have played a lot more
for sure but uh still probably with the
same result
yeah definitely definitely agree and
evich beating Vallejo in that game
Jeffrey Zhang jongvikolevski Victor
holding that position together and uh
Dimitri and Drake and crushing Emery
Chan
in their first game I also had a
position to show you between Jorge Corey
uh Peruvian number one was facing
um
uh Sandra mareko from Argentina and look
at this position Mariko
oh what happened here
some he's still my Beating Heart wow
Khan was destroyed
apparently Rook F6 yeah
yeah dangerous attack yeah looks totally
winning of course slightly risky for
black just a little little weakness of
the king
yeah same problem with Jerry book uh
position sounds good basis blockade but
getting mated yeah yeah but arcade I
mean extra exchange what else could you
ask for
okay so that is another result which is
about to be in the books
I'm looking around to see what other
interesting games I want to check into
the ladies
as well
um
but uh first I'm just looking around to
see if there's any
any games that are about to end
decisively
yell fun yeah let's check back into gal
fund's game
Boris having trouble converting this it
seems like he was crushing now he's
definitely better but maybe not as much
as he would have liked to be yeah the
Knight on H7 is is
ugly but uh but at the same time uh you
can't win you know the the bishop
because it's now finally uh The Rook
finally the road yeah we understand the
Deep the Deep Behind The Rook A7 move
that now it simply protects it's
interesting ending you know uh why I
mean it still should be better for white
because black in fact now what if I just
Advance with the king I mean uh what
What's black uh
[Music]
well black goes Knight f8 Rook F7 and
Knight D7 so it's it is true but still
should be better for white I think
somehow and of course and of course uh
the pawn on C6 would be hanging
um
and we we have to also think that maybe
uh B5 was not the only move maybe B6 is
a bit better who knows but still looks
still better for why that is true and of
course we of course uh because because
the because the move uh
B5 is forced anyway we don't even have
to provoke it with uh moves like root G1
maybe we can immediately Advance the
king
yep
I mean I don't think I don't think
you're going to go uh Rook A8 so B fight
must be played and then maybe
um
maybe I can play Rook C1 immediately and
collect the pawn
right yeah yeah exactly you're you're
getting yourself in a spot where you can
I mean if you want to spawn it seems
like you're gonna win the game well it's
looks like but of course Rook D7 makes a
lot of sense now because
um
I'm also not only attacking but on these
four but also
um if you take if you if you if you
defend which root be three then root be
six holds and sometimes Bishop H6 so the
feeling is white is better but it's not
cover
right no that makes that makes sense so
gal fund will continue to try to convert
let's look at the women's section and
let's see what's going on there we got
the top board garage gonna continues to
um expand her Advantage it seems like
she's just winning all of the pawns are
hanging yeah she's definitely going to
beat
um barring a miracle to her Jonah
on board one yeah we also we also have
this music game which seems to be a
little bit more competitive but it seems
like Todd's have has it managed to
create the requisite counter play
that looks very bad for black because
White's been able to penetrate a Black's
position and now sometimes okay the
Knight is much better uh White Knight is
much much better than Black's Bishop but
also sometimes white can simply take on
F7 and then take on D5 and playing Pawn
up or one Pawn or maybe two points up if
he wants if she wants to but that moves
like Rook D5 also I think are also
possible now if you and
and then I don't know uh let me see Rook
A2 is not really a big deal because I
check on the eight and if I want I can
all even ex exchange the quiz
no but the pawn is not even on D5 so I
mean it's right it's not on D5 but that
was white to move or it was black to
move
I think it was it is uh White to move
King H7 played by Toto uh okay
and what if what if I attack Rook F3
uh I guess for example three she wants
yeah but that's G4 I think oh yeah
Bishop G8 I think she wants Bishop G8
simply right but looks very dubious I
mean something like Knight G4 and try to
set up a rook sack here oh yeah it looks
looks very bad that's strong yeah yeah
so this is likely going to be a win we
we have to see Rook C4 now of course oh
yeah that is a move but uh and what I
like is there's already a big time
travel so maybe do you mind if we follow
this position not at all yeah let's see
how this unfolds and we have it on
camera as well so let me refresh and see
how Anna Anna plays Rook F3 indeed yeah
so Bishop G8 has to be expected no I
just don't see another way to defend
indeed as we're watching it I won't
switch to the game but I'll just say
that bibisara our survivor has beaten
jensay Abdu Malik that's a pretty big
upset so I'll do Malik will have to
cover with the white pieces tomorrow
she she
actually won it was a bit her best
result maybe
her career so far when she won Gibraltar
so it's really really a big big result
for
a Survivor yeah
yeah it is it is and thoughts of
struggling here 30 seconds let's see
where she puts the bishop
I just don't see another another move ah
she played Bishop H5 I don't like that
oh but G4 Rook a four maybe
oh
and what after okay for
C4 maybe yes if we're intercepting Anna
but then but then still see but there's
still Rook C4 should be very good for
black so
we'll see after let me see after G4 Rook
a four
Queen D5 is Bishop G4 and maybe I just
moved my Rook somewhere to oh I just go
sorry I just go Rook a fate and mate is
next no in which in which position C4
Queen D no no Queen D5 Bishop G4 and
True f8 Looks like mate I do have Queen
E4 check though maybe oh but then you
take a knight G6 yeah looks like oh
let's see there's stuff is happening
here
um let's have a look
okay G4 okay Queen B6 was played not
Queen takes D5
but feeling is that Queen is a bit
misplaced but it also makes sense I mean
uh The Rook is attacked but what if
we're looking seven
oh yeah rookie seven GH
rookie five and May and then you don't
have the move Rook takes H6 because the
I is that made no I don't think it's
that Queen on C2 could be guarding G6
that could be important in the end yeah
but let's see Tottenham for 40 seconds
she's gonna have to move she took on uh
but that looks like okay let's see three
no she took on G4 which also makes sense
because if you but
uh I mean she took Bishop takes G4 so
Queen C7 Bishop takes F3 you know so
um Knight takes and Rook Jesus that's
what Rook H6 is made okay of course yeah
Yep this one leads to first made because
then Queen C7 is checked yeah that's a
blunder by concept we'll honestly it
oh no yeah oh
wow
ah incredible and now is black winning
after Bishop F3 Knight dates Rook G4
check I don't think you think it's
winning I don't know wait a second what
if you play rather than playing Rook G4
immediately
all right no no Rook G40 what does I do
if you go King King H3 then I guess
we have five wins no uh I don't see it I
don't well
yeah looks like winning simply because
the Knight is attacked and of course you
have all this uh oh that you've got oh I
don't do you think she often draw or I
think she offered a draw that they said
something to each other I think she took
an F3 and after the driving she's very
worried
about her the prospects in this position
yeah she has every every reason I mean
oh my goodness
I think she's just lost I mean uh
so is there anything after King H3 Queen
F5 maybe there's some crazy move well
except you of course you can take on H6
can you Queen D7 is Queen F3 mate no
uh
Rook of six
[Applause]
oh my God wait a second we got six Keys
before all of a sudden white is better
white wish yeah which means they both
made a mistake one made a mistake by
offering a draw and the other by
accepting by not playing it so uh Plaza
has given that check I don't think Anna
sees it yet but of course it's also true
I don't need to okay King H3 what about
move like Rook F4 why do I have to
because I still want to work H6 then
ah of course yes of course
do you think she sees okay I mean you
refresh she
you think she they both see the the move
I don't think I mean at this point Santa
has to go queen of five I think and then
the question is will Anna find no no no
not in 40 seconds she can also play
Queen E4 sorry but then Queenie before
she's playing at five
okay will honestly work of Queen E4
maybe there was Queen of seven and then
Rook F4 maybe oh she finds it there it
is unbelievable she couldn't find Rook
H6 is yeah
and now of course uh my lands no Rook
takes H4 of course
and then uh take
King G3 and then maybe some chances
should be lost of course but maybe I was
kind of checking still what if I just
keep checking on G6 and then H5
yeah you have to try and they're
definitely drawing chances some people
have two pawns for the piece in fact
that's what has happened
for the moment okay good
and then
so King
G3 I guess yeah King G3 Queen G6 and
then you have to hide to G2 and queen G3
maybe and then
Queen E4 with chances maybe or not yeah
no for sure I mean two pawns the king is
safe No it should be winning of course
somehow I don't know yeah and I feel
like after such a blow but it's not it's
very hard to it's not true it's not so
easy because if you if you cover the
check with Queen G3 Queen E4 next and
then I mean I I already have two pawns
so if you if you try to exchange with
Queen E5 then still Queen G4 comes so
it's not so easy to to unpin and of
course if we exchange with B4 that would
be different
yeah then that might be close to a draw
we are going to go on a quick break
we're going to keep this game open so
you guys can see the the time scramble
um as time control is always made but
incredible stuff going on in music
abrahamian we'll be right back with more
action from round two of the fideo World
Cup don't go anywhere we'll be back in a
few
[Music]
foreign
World Cup presented by chess.com the
round two is underway a lot of results
coming in but before we delve back into
the games something funny was caught on
camera at the start of the round
in our producing team working so hard to
bring that to you let's watch so it's a
good view of the start of the rounds uh
the players are taking their seats you
can see uh in the front of your camera
there cindarov has already taken to see
with the black pieces and there comes
alireza in the gray suit okay we're
about to do that we're about to see
headshaco
okay let's play the play-by-play Watch
What Happens a little mishap there as
one side tries to high five the other
with a handshake and back and forth they
go a little bit of a mishap at the start
of the round that's all right
miscoordination right epic epic level
they shouldn't yeah they shouldn't be in
the same team I think you know
that is yeah no they it's not yeah if
they ever join a basketball team or
something definitely no chemistry yeah
funny stuff funny stuff okay so we have
thought of trying to make a draw here
with the black we'll keep an eye on that
game
let's come back to the open section for
a little while and see how
some of the some of the games are doing
uh I want to start with an issues game
I think he's on the path to winning I'm
not sure though
well
this seems Seems so what's going on here
I mean Rook H7 is force yeah seven is
fours yeah check and then and then
somehow okay take yeah it looks looks
winning of course yeah yeah I mean
Knight F3 for some reason uh or just go
back to to H5 also I mean you don't have
to to win quick immediately I mean or
also A5 B6 but I I would just keep my
phone on it Rook H5 back and then a five
and then B6 no this looks completely
winning I thought maybe what you could
do is is force The Rook trade and just
try to punch the pawn through on the
queen side also good yeah also good many
options yeah yeah this is completely
winning position uh another result
that's about to happen
is uh pragnananda is about to defeat
Gabrielle sardisi a very nice positional
game yeah my pride he had a serious
Advantage but a serious positional
Advantage after the opening in the I
think black played quite passively in
this coach they didn't went for the most
critical lines and then slowly he just
got he couldn't uh resist you know and
but again after the opening it was a
very solid positional Advantage for
white
yeah now at some point I I think maybe
B6 allowed the Knight to come to C6
still black was uh pawned down no even
uh not oh yeah he was a Founder wasn't
he
and he wasn't able to manufacture any
compensation
stabilizing the situation look at those
Exquisite Queen Maneuvers and back to E6
to E7 yeah to C7 and the King escaping
the checks beautifully
yeah it looked very convincing win yeah
indeed Prague wins I mean Prague he beat
me very easily uh in two years ago
almost in Gibraltar uh and uh since then
I'm sure he's he's even stronger now so
I wouldn't be surprised if he uh
advances very very far in this world cup
also Atari B barev
oh just seems like evgeny didn't manage
to stay afloat in that end game
before yeah the typical bat French
Bishop yeah right and it never got good
it's just still bad
yep yeah and I remember the feeling was
black was fine somehow in that game but
um
uh for sure he missed something
right and um I remember I had a camp
with Beret many many years ago he was a
guest at a camp that I attended and he
was showing some lines in the French and
he was complaining about how bad of an
opening the French is and
I think it was it a bad mood that day
and we were all asking him so why are
you why are you playing it and he kind
of snapped well do you know of anything
better
I was like well maybe in the night wrong
nobody said anything you know one of the
reasons we repeat our mistakes uh
because we we know what will happen
after after we repeat them somehow we
sometimes we prefer the the known bat
so
the known evil let's say yeah yeah
exactly the evil that we know we know
how how bad it's going to be and that's
a great point we are kind of used to it
already so uh in a way
right right now swindler is uh we
haven't looked at svidler in a while
he's had the white pieces against
Salinas who of course play that
incredible game
against Anderson in the first round
but uh it seems like he is slipping off
of the ledge here Peter is just playing
in his usual classy style completely
under control yeah this shouldn't be a
problem for white to win
um two points up is small enough and and
not only to pause up but of course uh
complete control of on the board and uh
and positional advantage in fact
so this is this is all over practically
yeah yeah this should be and Alex Evan
weitzer check they drew so you're
getting Alexa wasn't able to to make
anything of that position
but okay I mean boy to check obviously
is such a strong player
also
also have an interesting position here
as Spain I think is defeating chaparino
uh is that black to move yeah I mean
these pawns
um let me see
okay the pawn obviously is hanging so it
looks like black is going to lose his
piece so what about the move like uh
so for the moment Rook A7 somehow I I
you know I'm
feeling is black has some chances now
what if I just play A5 here
I mean I my idea is to to somehow
Advance
um so okay I'm giving that phone but
then
A4 and how do you improve I mean Bishop
goes to B2 I guess no uh yeah I'll go
Bishop A3 and then maybe should be
pointers yeah Bishop B2 and then and
then yeah and then then if once you
promote uh I I have no way to to advance
with the kick because I white has to uh
black has to still defend the E5 Pawn
yeah this looks winning
and if and if you go C4 it could be the
same problem
uh but but then what what if but then
maybe
yeah if he goes if he goes C4
um well what does white do here though
do you which phone do you stop I mean if
you go Bishop C2 it makes sense no and
and then it's not easy to make a move
for black
you just have to wait with the kick so I
I would place my my
um Bishop to C3 with the same idea that
is to take on E5 foreign
look at the king domination it's
completely dominating Black's King well
I mean uh maybe I move my my rook and
then if you go Bishop C3 then King D6
but still uh it's not clear
uh okay Rook imagine Rook Rook Rook gate
I mean not to f8 uh yeah but or or if I
go King D6 immediately how doing but how
does Okay Bishop C3 move my king G8 uh
Rook G8 sorry Rook G8 then I go King A7
and then I uh and then I have to run
all right so A5 no uh yeah for example
A5 yeah because now okay but now I'll
just take it I'll take an A5 but if you
take then of course King moves to
to be fine I apologize for that let me
make the moves but maybe so we were
saying
I mean maybe then I don't go A5 maybe I
go
King C6 forcing you to uh to promote
and then looking
should be winning for white of course
and then King B5 you take King before
and then uh that's gotta be winning like
Bishop D4 or even oh check yeah yeah
it's winning five so maybe some some off
chances here for Chop Arena but it just
doesn't seem like it's it's enough of
what is precise so that game probably
going to be decisive let's have a look
at the end game from for Rouge against
cindarov
which was looking quite unpleasant for
alireza for a long time
but um
okay but now it seems like he's probably
the worst behind him much closer for you
for equal to equality I mean uh because
Knight C5 that's a perfect square I for
tonight and then why it has two options
to no that would be Rook B2 that would
is that why to move in fact it is way to
move so white could take the pawn oh
what was then Black's last so so you
mean the backlit Rook 86 in this
position
ah bishopsy zero k6 and I suppose the
idea is to play Rook A3 and go for
positional domination but something like
Bishop B3 just looks and why could he
even end up being better at some of
these positions if that a pawn gets gets
set in motion well maybe G4 and take
only four and then the Knight goes back
to C5 but something for sure something's
blacks done uh something very wrong
because I I just uh but still it should
be kind of equal I mean if I stay it's
not so easy to advance in fact even if
you advance your oppon to A5 maybe I
come with the King to C7 and stay but
again against Black's done something
very wrong because at some point uh I
don't see any progress made by black but
I see
um
that is happening in fact yeah it is
Knight C5 we're going to see Rook B2
Rook a three
and you know
we'll see what happens there but it
looks like farouja is has stabilized the
situation yeah for the most part I think
white is out of danger at least you know
okay uh
shouldn't be losing maybe not winning
but she'll be losing of course
absolutely definitely
all right so our Russian code beating
ivanishovic
as well
and one could call that a an expected
result program under defeating sergeisi
and its official ragher and pioren will
make a draw most games have already
ended we just got a couple here
that are left Bach and savian Benjamin
trying to push him in a rook end game
but that also will probably land in a
draw
and high commercial roadstand that's
another game I'm spotting here he's
probably going to win against Mustafa
yomaz not sure what to make of this
position though
oh let me see it is black to move now
wow it's very interesting in fact I'm
not sure it's uh it's winning if in a
way I mean uh the black only has uh of
course without Quince on the board
uh it's not easy and then let me see a
what about the move like
uh better check
check for this and
check
um
so the problem of the move Queen D3 is
Queen H5 no and then
King D2 Bishop B4 King C2 and the King
runs uh Rook C6 check is King B1 are you
but no you're losing your Rook now
so oh
A2 and and Rook C1 that is that is a key
move actually yeah so what I mean I just
it looks totally forced oh except except
that white can go King F1 instead of
King D2
yeah but there's no checks and this has
to be losing a queen after three maybe
yes and the awkward H4 also looks good
but right somehow I would I would go
Queen F3 probably and of course yeah
and then maybe
yeah looks looks lost
it works very very bad for
white here if you find 25 he just did
you've played it very very quickly he's
got 30 minutes on the clock yeah this
game is
quite close to being over yeah
quite close to being over still not over
because yeah again Queen I I guess
um
well maybe maybe
King F1 queen queen F3 and maybe still
last chances uh Queen D1
and then I mean that's the best I can
find it looks but looks bad
yeah I would imagine
yeah
and taking is not wait can you take and
go
Bishop H2
and troops you on and promote I think
yeah but maybe Rook D2 no uh but but
again maybe no no it should be somehow
even Bishop B4 should be somehow winning
because Rook A1 Rook A6 Rook A2 Bishop
goes to B2 and this should be winning
somehow I guess no uh yeah this this
line is also winning no no no I mean
white goes through K2
and then I place yeah this should be
winning of course but
um but yeah but maybe there are other
moves
yeah yeah that makes sense and he
definitely should try it I mean this
queen D3 I think two is very Elementary
line I don't see anything better for
white because uh King F3 shouldn't be a
move now because uh check on H5 I don't
believe it moves like King E4 right
so yeah there's this this is probably
going to get checkmated
okay Ivan
where exactly is the maid here I mean I
guess it's
Rook G4 and queen B5 even
yeah okay maybe not immediately but uh
this should be winning of course
something yeah Queen B5 is here just
cutting the king off I mean yeah there's
a million ways to win and he'll he'll
find something
um all right and we also have the L Sean
mvo game that's not karyakan one he beat
up very convincingly so that's the
highest rated game
that's still going on and elshon has
made a lot of progress here toward
coming back in this game but still he's
got some problems I supposed to solve
with such a weak kick
well you should maybe push his phone to
C5 I I guess and and meet the move
rookie 8 by uh Queen DC
right
so yeah it's not possible of course yeah
that's the best uh place for the quid
and then of course he's advancing his
Pawn so looks interesting I don't I
don't know what exactly uh is happening
in this game
um yeah it's it seems like it's gotten
very messy yeah because uh if you if
black tries to exchange the pawn the
the Bishops with Bishop H6 there are
additional uh the pawn would be hanging
on D4 and then even moves like you know
uh rookie 3
in the future well I don't know if there
are uh so you
dangerous but maybe that's maybe bishop
86 pounds be played because if you
exchange somehow uh we need the the
square E3 for the king for The Rook uh
yeah and that is a pretty big threat at
this point yeah you have to be somehow
dealt with by white
yeah I mean maybe some still some
chances for an advantage but not
not nearly what it was previously or so
it seems
but still I mean it's it's very
interesting uh position Now with uh on
okay and it's now we see still the white
king is still more more exposed than
blacks so uh in this case I would take
black maybe but uh there's the feeling
is there should be a way for black to to
for white to save the game I don't know
and of course C5 is is not the only move
maybe I don't know
uh maybe they should there are others
maybe starting with Queen D2 D3
immediately is even better maybe I don't
know because then
after rookie8 I don't have to
um
play C5 because sometimes the pawn is
even hanging so even moves like okay
Rook A1 a possible and then uh okay
seven yeah yeah so or Rook C2 Rook C2 to
E2 so uh
yeah no that's interesting now
um C5 has been played by
okay so uh rookie eight I guess
yeah rookie 8 probably will be playing
Queen D3 will get this position and I
think mvl yeah to test why he has to
play Bishop H6
yeah and now uh the other option for
white is to start immediately with Rook
A1 because the difference is if black
takes of course the king is cut on this
uh
on the seventh uh rank it's not good
then Queen C5 Maybe
oh yeah of course you're right
completely yeah because that would be
nice but uh because of Queen C5 uh we
don't have this option and what about
and it's it's a problem how to protect
the pawn a free Pawn you know yeah the
rookie three move is a big problem big
problem I just don't uh okay
yeah
yeah this is the critical position it
doesn't look impressive but once rookie
three is played it could get mated
really quickly
yeah
so and of course sometimes uh the yeah
the the the the queen on D3 defends
everything and once it's removed uh then
everything falls apart even if you
protect somehow the pawn on F3 then you
have also another problem with Queen F7
taking on B3 and it really looks bad
mm-hmm
yeah that makes sense and so many
threats here
or uh let me see uh what if what if
white starts ah it's another problem we
can't even play King C2 because Queen C5
checks so yeah that Pawn's hanging on
top of everything else wow something has
happened Gary looks like here he has one
yeah he won yeah he gave check on H5 and
I think his opponent resigned yeah it
was a good position yeah just one king
C4 complete domination nice game by
Anish
a bit soft drink code white which is you
know one could say an expected result
but Gary has been writing that
incredible wave of confidence and he
continues
actually convincing Victory you know my
prediction is that the those who did
well from the beginning of the year they
will do well also in the world cup and I
take Anish also Maxim and that's that's
why one of the reasons I I thought uh
Wesley saw uh would have a fairly good
chances to to do well also you know so
um
so yeah G4 was nice the Final Touch
because it looks like King F4 you know
okay he checked yeah okay so if we go
back yeah Rook H2 check and King C4 I
think C4 and now if King F4 I think he
was planning to go G5 and G6 simply and
there is maybe a trick with Knight F3
oh but then still we would have uh
that's not
that's not made no uh I mean I can't I
can't take uh
I can't take uh
yeah I mean you could go like no no I
mean look at five the my knight is
hanging somehow it's not made
yeah maybe it's it's a question why did
he exactly resign yeah what what was the
G5 is Knight F3 maybe check first
because you can't go back to E5 I go G6
yeah King G3 yeah but now I go G6 or
yeah that's true or just take even or
even take on C5 first and it's uh you
don't have to no yeah like funds are
contained and now it goes to six yeah
this is winning of course right but of
course you should have been tried yeah
of course
and yeah this is this is winning yeah so
check is very important
that is true so in any case resignation
followed by savchenko we just have a
handful of games remaining we have Boris
gal fund continuing his effort to
convert and he's about to win black is
that he never never got out of the get
out of the gates here
these D font is running up the board I
think this is game over
powerful when I
yeah very convincing effort by gelfand
and it's funny we have the exact same
end game in Blue Bell Meredith that we
did in
zag and Sev against Haria
um
similar should be a this should should
be it is for sure theoretical draws and
the why so many chances to push the pawn
on F5 and advance and sometimes of
course
um
there are if that happens of course uh
white would get chances because even if
you lose
the G3 Pawn especially I the white king
could hide to F6 maybe right but
objectively it should be a draw of
course I mean uh probably what black
should do is to wait on the fourth rank
or maybe the way the effect the way uh
egg does defense is good because he
doesn't even allow the move to G4
because the executive he was able to
play G4 but now for example you don't
have you can't do that and you need your
Rook to support uh the king you know you
have to go back
with the rook and then cover from the
checks but it's too slow anyway of
course yeah so probably with plenty of
time does it's going to hold against
bluebound
um we are going to go on another quick
break most of the results are coming in
we'll be bringing you more of the action
from the fide Worlds Cup when we come
back in a few don't go anywhere
[Music]
foreign
Worlds Cup those of you just joining
quick update on two parallel situations
the first is that Levon aronian sadly
has a forfeit this morning's round
against Bobby Chang
uh due to uh symptoms of fever that he
had exhibited earlier he might play the
second game tomorrow we'll find out soon
the second of course and we think Maria
melanova for providing information as
soon as it occurred
Fabiano caruanas game against megaranzo
was held up and eventually forfeited and
Fabiano's favor when megaranto's kova
test came back positive both players are
apparently isolating in their hotel
rooms and again that is a actively
unfolding situation
um we will be bringing you facts as they
arrive and uh probably there will be
more clarity on the situation later
today
there's Clarity on a lot of the games
though
um that are going on in the World's Cup
most games are over
um we do have gukesh against dubov up on
the screen right now and music against
tatv up on camera lots of stuff going on
though vessel and in this game he goes
E6 in this position
with the idea of f66 Rook takes C6 that
I think was a draw
but do Bob didn't feel comfortable about
this and instead he goes Bishop B2
oh
group C2 okay
you should text and I guess what he
wants
is a check followed by Bishop D4
but very strong threat of this but but
that's
um one second what about the move like
Queen E4 now are you going to make me uh
Bishop F2 Bishop F2 should be runs to
Queen E5 I don't know it looks like uh I
guess I have to make a drop yeah okay
because if you go up you'll get of
course here yeah it's me or maybe he
simply forced uh
uh founder of because Rook C1 is
immediately a draw of course uh in this
position but we don't see anything
better
uh
and again Rook C2 what about Rook C2
then we have check check and check from
E1 that might only be asking for trouble
I think whoops but maybe I maybe yeah
but maybe still white can try to go to
F2 or not oh that's made from E3 oh okay
that's mate yay three and again H5
yeah yep yeah so this is bad and white
could also go Rook C1 here I think yeah
of course is the cleanest way to to make
a draws is to draw yeah swindler wins by
the way as I expected he's touching his
he's touching his uh Rook his Rook yeah
he's gonna go Roxy one this will be a
draw any second
by the way halt gushes uh
[Music]
15 I think 15. not bad yeah not bad yeah
not bad at all I I'm not positive though
it could be a little bit older it could
be a little bit younger
yeah I mean
not bad
okay so we have this game we'll keep our
keep our eyes on it as it as it winds
down gelfand is also about to win in
fact he played Rook C1 and I think they
they should be about to agree a drawing
yeah yep
taking a seat and there's a very
interesting game I have to say uh I'm
curious what a computer would say uh but
it was interesting very short very very
sharp yeah many complications yeah it
seemed like Lucas had an initiative at
some point then duboff had an initiative
it was back and forth and it was a
really really uh good game to analyze
for grunfeld enthusiasts and
chefs enthusiasts alike and gal find us
also won in parallel beautiful final
position with zugzvan wherever the King
goes The Rook moves and attacks the
bishop if the bishop moves then The Rook
uh f8 is also possible
for his girlfriend the legend he beats
Eric Braun's strong German GM
in their first game
yeah convincing win
indeed and
um what else is going on I mean uh that
ending between music and tatif I I just
don't know how to I mean to evaluate it
because of course if the if the on the
D5 Pawn Falls then of course white
should be winning but and if the quiz
exchanged I don't know because it all
depends on a game of uh between black
king for example here it depends on the
activity of the king could have done
this but she she refrained from training
quiz to me it seems very dryish with
yeah it looks closer to a draw because
uh what white has of course to do is to
I bet I guess is to uh not to advance
the pawn from F2 because that that pawn
could be easily exchanged but right yeah
again of course with Queens of course uh
looks easy you to defend but uh I I
believe there there's a plan for white
to somehow place the queen on D4 and
then maybe try to transfer her knight
from F3 to E3 and collect the pawn if
that happens of course but and meanwhile
black has to some all the time check so
it is interesting but of course uh the
the it's also true that the white king
can go somewhere to E2 even to F to F1
so uh I would consider myself uh placing
the queen on D4 not on H5
interesting centralize it yeah here I
guess 26 check is probably going to
happen Tata is running low on time
though she's she's down to eight minutes
again after time control was made so I
think she spent a very long time
considering that Queen trade and maybe
that was a good psychological tool to
get her to use her time that's I think
check was played and then uh King G3 so
now the problem of course is that uh if
if Queen D6 uh is is played then maybe
Queen E5 is stronger because the king is
is strong because the king is uh away
you know that's one option and the other
is to go 95. mm-hmm
yeah by the way but I could go Queen G6
here again yeah Queen G6 Queen G4 and
same stuff yeah
I think she should go for it because her
time is dwindling it just seems like if
she keeps the Queens eventually White's
gonna have some sort of a chance yeah
and if it's true that she actually got a
draw for and she declined then
psychologically it's very difficult to
you know to defense position which
um but of course she she believes she
was winning she missed the it's easy she
missed this rock have sex yeah it is
easy to miss him off like Rook F6 it
looks like uh that's over now uh
otherwise otherwise a move like Queen E4
uh deserves also retention you know not
only Queen F5 as in the game indeed and
a couple of other results in the ladies
section gunana beating sukhander with
the black pieces
uh gershard beating italic
uh danielian beating will Maga lots of
close matches Carissa bidding Natalya
buxa
um
and we still have a very interesting we
have two interesting positions we have
Karina sifka
pushed back against Anna shenana
[Music]
I don't know what to make of this
position looks like white is better
optically but maybe it's not so simple
maybe because the material is not
so much now okay if white as long as why
black doesn't get mated uh
well
looks very interesting in fact uh let me
see
so do we have to keep the quiz on the
board or not okay if black takes if only
five then of course Knight E5 would be a
problem because it's immediate made but
if white takes then and plays 95 then I
think we we have to Simply move
somewhere The Rook we're happy I guess
yeah but but still looks bad somehow
even if I just play Bishop F3 with the
idea to go uh or H3 with the idea to go
to G7 but maybe yeah yeah Rook H Bishop
H3 or Bishop F3 and it's not so easy to
stop the move Rook G7 now uh right and I
guess it's important to point out that
like if the record moved elsewhere then
Bishop takes E6 was a very nice win is
this of course this checkmate
so it definitely looks like yeah it
looks dangerous for black but um
uh well
if we make any move I don't know just
move the king I I think she's taken it
makes sense of course yeah very gives a
lot of clarity to the position and um
and then Rook Cafe seems like it's the
only move
yeah and then and then white moves the
bishop and again creates that pressure
down the G file and then a pleasant
position I would I would play
um Bishop H3 not F3 just to keep an eye
on on the E6 Pawn because now even if
you go Bishop F3 then 98 stops you know
uh the The Rook G7 move yeah so
definitely definitely good chances here
for what I I want to take a look at the
mvl game because
apparently there have been a lot of
developments there and none of them good
for Maxime
who is actually Let me refresh I heard
he's losing
he is losing I think
oh what oh unbelievable
very smartly dropped the bishop back and
started pushing the pawn again I think
Bishop H6 was kind of a yeah no-brainer
there
else I'm collecting looks like big
trouble for black
so Rook C7 I just don't know Rook A7 I
don't know what he's planning to do but
here Queen E4 I think and then Bishop F4
yes yeah so Rook A7 is a bit more active
but I don't think it it's only one check
I don't think it's uh it makes a big
difference no because anyway white can
okay uh
yeah Queen E4 still we need four okay
for the moment for the moment Rook B7 is
not really a big threat maybe because
the pawn on B3 is hanging Maybe
so I I don't know I
well it looks bad for black that's true
but
um maybe some chances and I'll show us
seven minutes that's not a lot of time
but even yeah it's also not exactly
clear what uh black stresses I mean you
have to somehow stop maybe what he has
to do is to place his Bishop on G3 and
then I don't know I will see what
happens but looks bad because okay the
problem default would be hanging yeah
and of course white can simply go
something like King C2
and then yeah the King has a lot of safe
spots here
wow and then we all thinking this
position q1 check also doesn't do
anything looks yeah I think he tried to
improve my idea with he realized he
needs to exchange the bishop but he
missed the very good idea of Bishop D2
so obviously Bishop H6 was really strong
there uh
because that would for sure exchange the
Bishops and now yeah Rook C7 was played
um let me see I think those are my moves
yeah no he's still thinking after Bishop
G5 what about move like D3 okay even
yeah okay DC
there's not enough or anyway and here's
a nice detail after rookie seven you can
already take into refv7 if I can design
exactly yeah
game
which is pretty pretty understandable
okay well let's see what mvl does here
this is a
very important moment
this could be a huge upset yeah
particularly given the position that MBO
had
and in fact yeah I I said I I my
prediction I mean that's one of the
reasons I I never bet uh most of my
predictions are extremely bad so I just
said that those who did well will
continue during the year will score well
do in the world cup but in fact for the
moment it could be that Maxim okay it's
it's not over I mean he would have
um still the white pieces in the second
game but and of course still he's still
he's still he's only in trouble it
doesn't but we don't know if he's losing
so right
but I guess Maxime also a struggle I
mean other than the Croatia tournament
he he has struggled a lot during covet
in the online events he had a couple
really really rough
events yeah so
yeah and actually we have a funny
statistic with ferger representing
France now he surpassed MBL so farouza
is now the French number one
and I'm sure MBL wants to change that
this tournament but the way this game is
going it's not going to change
that much
but well
um
well I mean
anyway he's had a good year I think by
winning Croatia uh I think
and he was in fact he finished second in
the candidates uh it's okay it's not of
course what he he went for after the
first leg but still okay
um
and future of course he is much much
younger and but still he needs to
advance uh in the cycle you know
yeah and 24 okay rookie seven plays so
he he's refrained from book C7 and now
Queen E4 looks incredibly strong let's
see if Elton John finds it but again it
me it makes a more sense to place the
Rook on A7 it's a more active Place
somehow then I'm done mostly something I
don't know what happened
I don't see
[Music]
um
I just don't see the position now I
think Queenie four was played
not yet I think he's still thinking this
is a different board it's just a
different board
that's hero Giorgio against maxudlo
which I think should end in a draw and
this is the position and we'll go back
come back to the elshon game in just a
second yeah this is a dead draw yeah
so that's going to be a drug you or give
that's a great result for him
um
and there is lack of gretcherson which
is a
looks like a dominant position for a
Maxime
so he's probably going to win this one
against fewer of our Granderson from
Iceland
that leaves only a handful of game is
still playing solemn but definitely the
most interesting position is the one
that in moradia body mvl has elshon
five minutes on the clock he needs to
make a move soon that would be a big
surprise of course if he wins yeah
because one of the favorites uh imagine
imagine Levon is not able to play
tomorrow it means that he'll be out and
then if Maxim loses then after the
second round will be with
um already two of the top favorites out
uh and it's a bit right
yeah no and you know it just shows how
difficult it is sometimes to beat these
100 GMS I mean elshon I've always
thought was underrated he's
he's capable of competing with with the
best of him
yeah but I I I've been thinking about
after Queen E4 that imagine black goes
something like Bishop G3 no and then
um we need for a played by the way yeah
okay it's
yeah
looks Bishop G3 and then I would maybe
even play F4 we did it before to
intercept the bishop to cut the bishop
and even even if you take by check uh
with check on D on B3 I don't think it's
enough simply because then uh I mean
Bishop G3 here for black
okay and four and then H4 for example
and I think I I would consider playing
even now Bishop Rook B7 looks like
winning because that's only one check as
far as I see on B3 and then of course
your king is still in trouble King moves
but now D3 but even D3 maybe
um
my idea was to hide on to to G4 but of
course you can do it what about what
about King D2 what's your next move I
mean now queen Queen City too ah sorry
sorry sorry of course and uh yeah I'm
getting almost mated yeah so King E3
yeah but I think I can Sundial I can sun
dial You Queen B6
King D3 Queen B1 and then I can do this
thing with and there's no way to advance
what if I go to E5
somehow because you don't have to check
from E7 I missed it that is true that is
true
okay no check King E5 and then Queen B5
is Queen D5 maybe so
um yeah
no no no no H3 Maybe
oh
it makes uh things
five maybe but yeah
it's complex very complex no maybe it
simply doesn't make sense for white
there should be another better move but
probably that's the best way for black
to play Queen Bishop G3 that just to try
to stop the you know the the pawn on but
the feeling is but it's bad for black of
course and I don't think white has to go
for this it was just yeah well it's
spoiled for Choice there
foreign
yeah yeah for sure so the position on
the camera of course is the gretzerson
game but like of so many strong Grand
Masters we don't pay attention but
there's so many games you know that and
um right
I mean even localesco is is playing you
play a very nice game against a shaman
okay is probably very happy to play
Hashem rather than adley and he's going
to win this first game when he found 94
should mate
on in one of these several ways so
that is basically in the can for
for Constantine
yeah they seem to be decided
yeah it is it is decided and
let's see solemn and indich are still in
a still basically in a middle game which
is hilarious because it's move 49.
yeah it's very interesting because uh my
impression is black spawn up no it and
also the Rook on B4 in fact it's only
defending it doesn't look like it's
stopping the advance of the phone so
black should be better simply you know
if if my uh but of course Bishop A2 is
also followed by Queen G4 also looks
dangerous so black has these problems
with uh to protecting the the E6 Pawn
but okay for the moment of course Rook
uh Rook D Rook d8 I don't see I don't
see anything wrong with that and then
Rook D6 and then of course I would place
my king to G8 looks very good for black
somehow
yeah King h8 and whites the Yap files
very precarious that Rook on B4 is sort
of stuck there because D4 is weak and
and also Solem has two minutes so it
just seems like yeah don't sleep on
ninja she's very strong
um but I want to come back to the elshon
game because stuff is happening in that
game Let me refresh once again to bring
you the latest
okay so mvl played H4 and Alshon said
thank you very much for the pawn I don't
get it at all this so what what was that
well I I think the feeling is that as I
said uh earlier there are situations
when maybe uh Maxim he felt he's lost
and then if you realize you're lost then
all the tricks works oh they're not they
don't work but they're Justified even
desperate uh moves like H4 but of course
I would have played Bishop G3 so he
wants to play he wants to place his
Bishop there but I think now
um is over
or is there some trick well there are
several checks of course and then maybe
I don't know if but the king runs to F1
so it's uh and then of course it can go
to H3 and then the the checks are would
be over it could you could even go Casey
too and even though you allow or xc1 I'm
not sure that does anything because Rook
B7 is totally devastating and also the
third of Checkmate yeah could couple
with the pawn promoting this is oh this
is completely lost it's completely lost
that is true so I'll show them with
three minutes that's the only hope I
think for Maxime
we're looking at another position the
camera shows Matt lakov's game uh very
close to winning also
yeah yeah he is
I don't see any any big trick for black
after Bishop G3 simply a couple of
checks uh but of course White's King
Black's Kings also exposed no uh and
every time you uh leave the seventh rank
with the The Rook of course then uh Rook
B7 is killing simply so yeah what you
don't want to do is go Rook B7
immediately though right because again
then it then it leads to this line and
there's no need to allow that yeah
that's true king E2 played by El Sean
Marty body wow but now Queen is seven
F4
a foreign King FC no
yeah
yeah I suppose this is still winning and
and he's Gary I think is expressing his
his pleasure with um with the way the
carwana situation has unfolded tweeting
who schedules the test so the results
come back during the game
and Anisha wow he won his game and
he's already uh already managed to tweet
yeah in that time yeah all right
so King E2 and blth thinking now he's on
camera elshon's got to be nervous though
he can sense that he's so close to
beating
beating MBL in this first game
well chicks makes no sense doesn't mean
because the King goes to uh H3
so it makes no sense again and queen C7
uh well it's also true that what if I
just go something like King D3 you know
uh are you going to
moved well even that looks
good now Queen moves to H2 ah
yeah I finished just for stronger and
maybe even move like like Queen uh
Bishop E1 stops but of course my idea
was of course to to check no my idea was
to check but maybe it makes no sense
simply sorry English too yeah okay seven
F4 F4 is good for sure I mean if for
it's not a difficult move to to be made
no uh security yeah yeah it's quite
straightforward actually well what about
Queen A5 after a four
yeah I mean this definitely mixes things
up because Queen D2 is a threat so yeah
al-shawn has his problems left to solve
it we're gonna go on a quick Break
um we'll keep this game on of course and
when we come back we'll be watching the
rest of this fascinating Affair between
elshon and Maxime as long as as well as
some of the other games
um let's take a quick break we'll be
back in a few a few minutes stay tuned
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the World Cup and as the
game is winding down we've got a couple
high profile matches still going
whose result is up in the air our
biggest well we see on camera yakovenko
Gabriel we'll bring that to you shortly
but first let's have a look at the
developments in moradia body against
mvl as elshon is on the cusp of winning
but maybe not so clear they've traded
Rooks wrestling and now he's trying to
escape the checks that are delivered by
the queen
yeah I mean uh I think what happened is
that El shank has made a huge serious
Mistake by not allowing the queen gong
to C7 so maybe now still of course he
has serious very good chances of winning
but it is not as easy it was uh and of
course it's now a matter of if white
would be able to escape from the checks
but of course it's very obvious that now
that
the because the the pawn on B7 is so
strong it can only still be only white
playing for win
right
yeah for sure and
okay
um where should the king how do we
escape the checks if you're al-shan
Diego King D7 I think he has to be 5.6 I
think he should go to F7 that's my
impression uh-huh and then once you
continue
uh to F7 and to f8 no f8 it's uh it's
you still have the check from H6 and
then of course the problem is if we play
with the King to F7 then Queen B3 is a
good check and then what about Queen B3
Queen E6 is not good because Queen B7
checks out check on F7 we we can't hide
on F7
we can go to E8 but again then the King
has to restart the process now my idea
was to go Queen C6 here I thought maybe
you can go Queen C6 of course and queen
F5 and then and now King E8 King Y8 and
uh the the and then King F7 and Bishop
F6 something like that yes yes two more
draws by the way Timor and yakovanco
Drew
so this should be winning somehow yeah
because well uh
he's 16 D7 let's see if he plays Queen
C6 and you're given maxulu also drive
that that was uh opposite color Bishop
yeah that was expected
foreign
yeah that's a good question
um
Shannon I might get another night in
Bishop end game they're still
playing and Tata was kind of Honda D5 as
you predicted white gets the Knight to
D4
so maybe good chances still to win and
now yeah I mean Tada might lose this
pawn it looks like I don't think she can
um keep the pawns because uh first of
all uh I mean queen E5
Queen if you go back to F7 then uh King
E3 and it checks are over and your queen
is uh
passive there and then
if you go back to E5 you said yeah I
mean queen E5
oh oh whoa whoa whoa what about G5 King
F5 but that then we still have uh and
this is first yeah Queen F7 is King G4
yeah it looks like it all works for
white for Queen F6 here yeah white is
white is so active here I feel like
Musiq is probably going to win this one
yes yes which would be quite uh quite
the heartbreaker
yeah and of course uh yeah this looks
like and of course
impression is black miss her uh her
chance to go for this similar ending
without quiz but with the with the King
much more active
yeah yeah that was slowly sort of
slipping here she's got three minutes
we're gonna keep an eye on this one I
still want to look at the elshon game I
think a lot of people are interested in
whether this is going to be an upset and
no this is let me again I I keep having
to refresh
okay so Queen C6 Queen F5 has been
played and now King E8 I think we'll
give elshon the chance to hide from the
checks he's got two minutes though
so this is going to be very close let's
see and Dominguez by the way also
drawing his game that basically only
leaves this game and Benjamin box game
what if I go Queenie six Queen B5 King
C8 you still have to check but now my
five yeah Queen C5 and then King d8
mm-hmm it also looks good now uh oh
checks are almost over and then right
right and then qv8 you just have a
handful
and then of course uh that would be the
end of the
checks looks like back my win also but
we'll
we'll get to that let's see what move
out Sean plays down in a minute on
camera we have um solemn against indich
which probably will end up an indicious
favor that would be a huge win with
black
again
and has made a move and that move is no
he hasn't made a move yet
I wish we could see
his camera but we don't control that of
course
um let's see
and
30 seconds will he play King E8 here
that's what we're expecting
okay there it is
he's fighting so if if Fabiano if
Fabiano wants to get the the price
Magnus got he should resign the second
game so they could you know so they
could uh play a normal match no
say that again I mean I mean if Fabiano
oh yeah
once the price Magnus got for fair play
he should just drop his Queen
um in the second game
indeed and he's tweeted uh just now the
following I hope Mr magrans is feeling
well he seemed to be completely fine
during the game so the way the match
ended was a very unpleasant track I'll
take a test tomorrow to determine if I
was exposed to covid and hopefully I can
continue the event after that so that is
a tweet from Fabiana carwana who won by
four but of course when megaranto cess
came back positive during the game
we'll continue monitoring that situation
and
Erdos and um blue balm of course as
expected drawing that Rick end game
what happened in ciprino's game he was
uh the ending that looked he was uh he
was losing of
let me check
um
he lost he lost
yeah it's referring I've lost
okay let's go back to Maxim Queen uh
King E8 was played and he checked on E5
so again well but we're missing uh or we
are not I mean queen G7 is existing
Queen G7 is nothing yeah because uh six
and and then of course maybe I cover
from I cover now with Bishop to E7 no
King D7 Queen F7 Bishop B7 Queen F5 it
just seems like a king a yeah but okay I
mean also at the end Bishop F4 still has
to be dealt with I think he resigned
maybe no he did resign
well I don't know do because the Kings
they're both wait a minute no way no way
there's no way this came in from
what
well did you did draw is it is that
possible
it is it's a draw
thank you Maxime got a draw for like uh
it's a it's a good price a good gift
yeah
are we missing something I mean
uh
no
I mean Alshon is in time pressure so
obviously well maybe I don't I do you
think he
he was considering uh something like
he was afraid of move like uh
but of course the move the the
king of seven threatens mate
so I think he was worried I mean if I
may I I think he was worried about this
position
but okay even Queen E4 I mean like
literally
it doesn't look like black is in try
white is in trouble losing no Queen no
zero yeah Queen E4 and queen D7
it should be seven and you can reside I
think
no but Queen E4 may be uh D3 was better
than
um but still yeah it just takes
expectancy three it's possible or queen
he's seven maybe in King f8 yeah okay
that's crazy but I guess he panicked so
let's come back to the malachov game
who is about to yeah it's over he just
made the second Queen
with check that's nice yep yep so well
okay uh I was just trying to say that
maybe Queen C7 exchange but of course
it's not it's not even possible so it's
ah they're still playing okay
it's a game over here
um let's check into the well we'll we'll
keep this game on camera Queen G8 played
and I think greterson is gonna resign
here she's just losing The Rook I mean
yep ah but the bishop the the other Rook
the other Queen is attacked so
um let's say
King f uh King f 6 has to be played and
what we should simply not blunder the
queen I think with with white
yeah I mean King F6 Queen d8
um and then King I don't know why he's
yeah it's it's just over
I think he's seven played but okay okay
Queen G7 and Queenie still
yeah King E7 Queen G7 King E6 28 and
we're gonna see a resignation
also Queen G4 looks interesting just to
collect all the pawns which
all right there it is Queen G7 King E6
and queen E8 is going to end the game
right here and right now
that's gonna leave only one game I would
definitely take on G4 and get the same
position but okay Queen E8 and take the
Knight with check also looks very good
for white
yeah I think it's time to resign he's
going to lose every piece on the board
and then get checkmated
we're gonna see a handshake right now we
do there it is and montlickov wins the
first game in very nice fashion against
Granderson
let's switch back to I think the last
game in the open section Bach against
Savion
I think Benjamin's about to win this
because F4 looks looks windy yeah
look swimming of course but yep and now
Rook H1 and very important this check on
G6
and you get mated if you go king of five
and if you go King H5 then white takes
and it's over exactly yeah so and Rook
F6 I don't see any I mean it's just
force no after of course white can black
and go to H5 but then still it's
completely not clear what to do after uh
move like King E4 or King F3 so uh
anything everything expect except Rook
F6 is uh winning
right and I should I should say that
there's also the solemn game which might
be the most competitive one
oh
this one's close
but still black should be much better no
I mean so many pawns up uh looks better
for what for black for sure
okay
G3 King F4 I don't know in fact uh was
it white to move
yeah this is why to move then of course
that's not so clear if Black's able to
uh protect uh his Pawns of course well
he's not doing that he's Touching The
Rock
because no
you once I don't know what it is that he
wants to play Rook D3 I believe that's a
mistake because uh now black has a
choice between uh B4 B3 and then of
course B2 would be uh
okay what about B4 now simply
yeah so B4
0 he wants to go back to D4 okay if you
go back then maybe
what if I go Rook B8 then I guess
this I guess I could do seven yeah and
then I go back yeah but and then it's
still still with some chances yeah yeah
so yeah maybe it's not as stupid as I
thought
initially and what if I go Rook A8
maybe it's better than
um but then maybe C6 proxy 6 and rookie
5 runs to D7 yeah nfa3 I can play Rook
A3 maybe yes yes okay 3d7 so some
tactics
still giving White Hope
although the time pressure yeah which is
going to be brutal
impression is black should be winning
somehow
yep yeah it certainly feels that way
Benjamin Bach
I think has one let me see
pretty sure no that game is still
ongoing but he's about to win that
second pawn and then he's gonna win the
game any second now against Savion
let's quickly look at the ladies section
um still music against tatev is ongoing
and the position on the board is
currently this one
and now they're in a full on time
scramble
yeah but then the queen should be on uh
not on F1 but on E1 because otherwise
that would be too easy I mean we the
queen only one stop prevents the white
king advancing
right which is what she's done but it's
winning somehow I mean we need three I
guess and then try to get the king into
the E file
Queen E3 looks should be winning but
maybe then I take and push G5 no should
be winning of course
yeah yeah that's this let's just played
it we need to ring him it's quite simple
I mean the point is you just get the
king in and you should save the pawn
yeah black was black played very
passively because uh now the even if you
push your
pawns I mean they are blocked easily by
uh by the working there's so much
difference in the activities of the K of
the kings that
um
so exchanging makes no sense and but if
but that that means that uh the pawn
will fall and then of course should be
just lost
yep I'm thought that was taking your
time but
King E6 King takes D5 and then this game
might go on for another hour but it
seems like Anna's quite
quite likely to grind her down here
okay back to the inditch game endic has
not moved yet after Rook D3
a Benjamin Bach is about to win so let's
show that real fast
okay this is not the position on the
board Let me refresh
um this is the position on the board
seven will resign any second now you can
see that on the camera really briefly
and that's going to leave one game in
each section
yeah this is over E7
yeah easy easy one
so
yeah we can we can watch this game until
it ends King H6 just D7 I think is the
simplest I like King F6 also I mean F6
is class cm
yeah by the way B4 was played
yeah and Rigby eight so there'll be uh
an exchange of the a pawn and b-pawn for
the one of these seven so now that that
will be I think it's important to uh if
I think why it's not going to be able to
protect the E5 Pawn because uh D7
loses to Rook D5 and then because the
pawn is on
um
because the pawn is on
The Rook is on A4 you you can't protect
your opponent well if only your king was
on G3 would be able to take and go King
F4 but always these these one one tempo
is decide these kinds of positions yes
that's the drama of Chess uh oh it's
always one temper or almost always
yeah and seven resigns
okay
Benjamin wins
Fabian will have to win with white
tomorrow which
you know is not impossible but very very
difficult Bach is extremely solid
and that leaves just this game
all right
well he's thinking after Rook V8 is
solemn
he's probably going to go D7 yeah I
don't see an alternative here can you
take on C6 Maybe
and then and then go D7 but that but
then of course simply Rook would take
root Rook would then take on uh maybe
what about
it
and this is losing
this is senseless
well briefly uh D7 is losing Rook CA
well Rook B4 could it be a move now wait
a second he's gone
would be what about Rook B4
and then and then ah but then of course
the The Rook can cover with ah I think I
understand what he wants he wants Rook
C4
book C4
and beef where no what am I saying B2
Rook B4
takes takes ah but then D7 will be a
threat at the end yeah yeah so he wants
to uh yeah you're right he wants uh Rook
C4 but uh or he's blundered this uh
let's see where there it is but then
just Rook takes Rook takes uh E5 should
be winning because I mean the only thing
black has to do to exchange the pawns
and to take the he takes check with
check the one on uh H7 no
or maybe she wants
maybe he wants uh to play D7 no and if
you what about simply b200 yeah rookie
five and then is that what you're with
your the line you're going down no B2 is
uh I think B2 is will be four now
before I just take before and take E5
and then I take H5 with track and I use
the B Pawn to no I was thinking about
it's yeah okay
he's gonna be two asintage yep and
solemn I think that hesitation shows
that he
did not think this properly through he
simply exchanges the pulse and finally
there will be two pounds up for for
black
yep
I mean there's no both both uh
both pawns are lost oh 51. yeah but
that's I don't think no just B1 Queen is
even winning B1 Queen is the simplest
because then and you go around you
collect all the pawns and you win
anything of course
you can in fact include A3 first
uh also yeah he's got an acquaintance
is just going to make a queen and win
taking its time but
yeah
yeah he's making the queen I think
solemn's going to resign here time to
resign yeah
because all of the pawns will be like I
mean even without the ape on its way but
yeah you think he's going to shake hands
and
and he takes it
yeah you can tell and this is just
feeling good about himself right about
now
it's goodbye because yeah Rook H5 or K5
and
it's all over
and that's the last game in the open
section we once this one is it was over
we'll track back into the music game and
probably start
putting the finishing touches on today's
broadcast
very eventful day
it's been really exciting I mean uh I
mean Maxim he was better I think after
the opening but then finally who is
extremely lucky to survive that game he
was lost but
um
okay I think the funny thing Vaseline is
after D7 Rook D1
white is going to end up winning the a
pawn at the end of the line but of
course H and G fonts is Elementary win
ah maybe he still wants to you know to
to continue no
like we're K8 in the end is going to win
the pawn you'll see it but
but of course it's an easy win for black
yeah but okay it will take some time
maybe
yeah very good
nicely done by indich
and he wins with black he only needs a
dratamar and
yeah music has won the pawn
um and has won the pawn and she's
definitely going to win this I think now
yeah yeah yeah yeah and what a day it
was we have drama of course we have the
karwana situation to monitor what it
appears will happen is Fabi will
probably not play tomorrow I mean I
don't know if the match will be
forfeited
I imagine
it will be but we will definitely
provide you with updates tomorrow we'll
do it for now because uh Fabi he he
tweeted uh that uh he when he said uh
that the the way the match was uh
finished he was he referring to the game
or the match probably the match probably
the match was forfeited it means they'll
probably have tomorrow off yeah it means
he knows that the match is over yeah yes
so he'll probably have tomorrow and the
day after that off um we we wish him the
best we wish my guarana the best and we
will provide you with updates but now it
is time for us as muzicook converts her
advantage to wrap up we're gonna leave
this game on
but it's time for us to sign off it has
been an incredible five hours of action
vessel in with surprises abounding
Magnus winning convincingly but some
other games
lots of incredible performances some
upsets and tomorrow will be a huge day
as many players have to win to stay in
the World Cup yeah but most most of the
favorites were convincing I would say
yep yeah I would say unbalanced you know
the top guys Gary played a beautiful
game we'll see how the lower rated GMS
try to try to win tomorrow you will not
want to miss the action it begins at 8
AM Eastern Sharp and it's time for us to
say goodbye vesselyn a great pleasure
commentating with you as usual
um and we will be back tomorrow morning
thank you to everybody uh for for
watching and for taking time out of your
busy weekdays and of course thank you to
our production team today for yet
another seamless broadcast we appreciate
everybody could not be possible without
you so thank you to all thank you to a
vesseline and we will be back
bright and early tomorrow morning
for day two of round two in the 2021
feed a World Cup presented by chess.com
for now we bid you goodbye have a great
rest of rest of your Thursday and we
will see you tomorrow
for the next round
goodbye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]